foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
come on
no I thought I lost some time I just
shot myself hello everyone this is your
daily dose of Internet this is Criminal
oh that was criminal I win
[Music]
what's good Turtle Squad it's your boy
the heck
[Music]
I'm too good at this game I'm gonna win
this [__] thing
and then this is always the next move oh
he surrendered I knew it guys we're
Geniuses
ready they have this chest rabbit that's
just terrible oh
in the computer
welcome back everyone to your favorite
Creator chess tournament hog Champs and
it is pogchamps 5 and it is day one I'm
Levy Rosman you might know me as Gotham
chess and I'm joined today by one half
of both says live Andrea Boathouse
Andrea how are you hello everyone I'm
super excited POG champs for me at least
is my favorite chest time of the year
because it really resonates with me it's
finally you know some chess I can follow
along and we have such an amazing lineup
this year things that people have been
waiting for for years so it's gonna be
an exciting time it is going to be an
exciting time we've got creators in all
walks of life from all over the world
representing except France this year for
some somehow we missed France but we'll
get them back next time uh let's remind
you of what the event format actually is
what pogchamps really is all about uh
it's four groups of four players and
that's around Robin style so everybody
plays everybody the top two finishers of
a group will make it to the championship
bracket the bottom two finishers we'll
make it to a consolation bracket so
everybody makes that out of the group
stage just with a slightly different uh
fate and then this is actually the most
high bullet point we've ever had for the
first time ever pogchamps is going to
have a live final hosted in Los Angeles
which is super super exciting Andrea are
you excited you just walked down the
street I don't know where you live I am
very excited does this mean you're gonna
be flying to L.A and you're gonna hang
out with your favorite Bolshevik sisters
too yes yes I think the contract is
signed for that I'm very excited oh
we've got the groups these are all the
good event if Levy's coming to La yes
it's a long flight uh so it's it's
definitely worth it let's tell everybody
about the groups uh let me draw your
attention to a couple of things here
everybody bottom of Group C not by
ranking just I don't know alphabetical
order xqc his fourth POG Champs event I
hope they're paying him a participation
fee already uh also in the same group as
tyler1 that is going to be an incredible
group to watch we've got cutie
Cinderella papa plaza in uh in group D
sapnap repping uh Minecraft and Group B
also daily dose of Internet he's playing
a bit later the sensation Frank in group
a Sea Dog the number one ranked player
in the entire event this is what's going
on in the group Central what's your
favorite group which group you got a
favorite group it's hard to pick
favorites but I just have to say it's
very funny the players we have we have
like someone like Sea Dog Who literally
could probably eat Ludwig for breakfast
like he has been playing chess growing
up he competed in twitch rival three
years ago the man loves chess and has
been playing for a long time and then on
the other side you have like tyler1
which don't get me wrong you know I love
League of Legends he plays them maybe
one game of chess in between his League
games and he has been trying to hit 200
but he has not done it yet so we have a
very nice diverse spectrum of talent
today but I think he lifts 200 on
everything like I'd like true yeah I'd
like to do the like I'd like to hit two
exactly no everyone has their strengths
and weaknesses and Tyler one must be a
very intimidating opponent to play I
hate to play him uh over the board so
it's good that It's All Digital there's
a lot of interesting matchups and like I
said a lot of creators from a lot of
different places some very experienced
in chess and some not and maybe the
people who are not are going to
Skyrocket up to A Thousand Eleven
Hundred we've seen it happen before we
have a lot of creators but we've only
got a few playing today so so let's jump
into today's matchups the very first
matchup that we have is Frank and a lot
of people in this chat are probably here
for Frank you might know him as Frank
Franks is here it's cheeky he's going up
against Jarvis Jarvis of course uh was
Justin Creator Clash uh and uh obviously
his training is mental as well as his
physical uh then we've got a group b
matchup coming up right after that which
is daily dose of Internet uh this is
yours we got to make him do it right in
the interview uh and then gasly uh and
Gastly is a musician he's a DJ so people
from everywhere like like I said I mean
just doing all sorts of different things
with their careers uh we've got Ginny
who you might have seen all sorts of
clips from her in different cities and
she's an IRL streamer and who doesn't
love tyler1 right like it's League of
Legends and it's chess and they are
exactly similar and will end the day
back in group a with sea dog versus
saikuno uh which of these matchups do
you think is going to be the most
exciting Andrea
uh you know exciting's the way to put it
I have to say I just don't know what to
expect expect for example we have
saikuno versus Sea Dog which I just gave
a bit of background on Sea Dog you know
while saikuno messaged me about four
days ago and he said hello I need help I
have a chess tournament coming up I said
hey what's up he said I started at 800
and I am now at 200 and then he asked
about openings and I said just push E4
and he seemed very confused once I
mentioned chest notation
um on the other hand we have matchups
like Gastly which is my Prodigy student
um he is a very well established DJ he
plays some of the biggest musical
festivals in the world like Ultra EDC
and um his next Endeavor right now is
chess he just finished six months of
touring and for the next month he wants
to take chess very seriously so I guess
today he will redeem or prove himself
I mean what better way to do that than
to play in POG Champs right there's
literally no better way I feel like to
take just seriously I mean there's a
world championship but I think POG
Champs is a little bit more prestigious
I'm excited I'm excited to see how Frank
does because it's a high pressure match
again for him and he's in the group with
the killer of the tournament which is
Sea Dog you just mentioned yeah Sea Dog
psychuno is a tough matchup for saikuno
Sea Dog play chess uh when he was in
school he played chess in middle school
I think he played it in high school then
he quit then he came back he's like 1200
he's played thousands of games uh and
obviously we're gonna get to see two
people we know nothing about a little
bit later which is ginny versus uh
versus Tyler like that we we I think
they've played a combined 50 games I
asked Ginny I was like hey you you need
help because I've seen she's just been
traveling the world and she said oh I
will try to speed around the game before
my matches so I tuned in her stream
today and she's not playing chess so we
have a very fun wild card and I'm very
excited to see what will happen of those
two games
wow that uh okay well that's very
exciting to see
um but our first matchup of the day is
Frank and Jarvis so let's just dive a
little bit deeper into Frank uh and well
and Jarvis I mean for lack of a better
word Frank the he you know what's
interesting he's a chess YouTube
sensation he's a tick tock sensation
first one day I was scrolling and I just
hear oh that's a cheeky move and I'm
like who is this dude it's so funny he
pre-moved the whole game that was his
original Tick Tock he's now got over 60
million views he plays on uh mostly he
streams mostly on YouTube plays on
chess.com all the time he's played over
a thousand games got up to 800 and he
hit a brick wall recently he got to 902
now he's down to around 800 and uh I
think we actually have a live view of
him he's right now on so he looks to be
praying I I hope to hear the word cheeky
today
yes we gotta do it give us a chicken
Fork Frank please we got we gotta do
like a bingo card for Frank like and
Cheeky's gonna be one of them I that
that's what he looks like he looks like
he's streaming from witness protection
usually
um he's rubbing his hands together you
know uh he's got an opponent that's
really mysterious too like a guy who
played chess a lot when he was younger
but now hasn't played a lot that's
Jarvis
um and uh I think Jarvis also has a
player card so we obviously shouldn't
disrespect him let's throw that up on
the screen uh Jarvis mentioned to me
briefly he's played some chess uh as a
teenager I think up to like a certain
age and then stopped YouTuber twitch
streamer does a lot of different content
he's been nominated for the streaming uh
the streamy awards multiple times he
does I like his content a lot very easy
stuff to throw up on the screen 10-15
minutes boom you laugh you have a good
time you know him well too right yeah
Jarvis to the man who can wear many hats
I have to say recently obviously he
fought in Creator clash with me but he
also has a huge podcast on YouTube
called the sad boys podcast reinterview
some of the biggest YouTubers in the
world so whether he's training for
boxing he doesn't interview me yeah
maybe he'll take us on one day you know
maybe before we make a good impression
today but he is playing your Prodigy
student so if anything he'll take me on
and not you because you should be
rooting against him no no I'm I'm
actively rooting for for good chess I am
definitely biased I'm slightly rooting
for Frank I I just want to see him
succeed uh I'm mostly looking forward to
the Frank C dog matchup I've already
been hyping Frank up a lot and it's
tough entry do you ever feel like in
these matchups like you're friends with
both you don't want anybody to lose yeah
no actually sapnap but the student I was
coaching asked me this morning he said
which one of me and ghastly are your
favorite student and I said I answered
the same thing when I asked my parents
that question about my sister and I and
I said I love both children equally and
I can't pick a side but
okay well uh I think it's game time I
think Frank and Jarvis are ready to go
all right uh I I mean I'm really excited
to see everything that you've taught
Frank because I know you guys have had a
lot of extensive chess lessons yeah
let's say let's say that no no let's
save all of that uh let's say well if he
wins in 10 moves he's my prodigy what
what opening do you think he's gonna
play you think he's gonna go for cheeky
trap
he he likes to play the fried liver ah
yes uh
so you know that goes well as they play
into your trap and then if not you're
kind of just like well what now
yeah that's that's exactly right don't
remind me
um yeah that's that's exactly how it's
actually uh it's okay it's gonna work
you know I'm sure it's very intimidating
for Jarvis to go up against such a huge
internet sensation of many platforms
like Frank so I I wouldn't underestimate
him
um no I'm I'm actually very very nervous
because uh
I yeah I I mean they they ah there we go
all right here's the game here's here's
your beautiful fried liver
uh
almost yeah he it he didn't play Knight
F3 but this is The Bishop's opening oh
great move by Jarvis by the way this
this removes all four move Checkmate
stuff
and uh now we're in a regular King spawn
I think that's a good sign as long as
Frank's not getting mated in the first
10 moves this is this is very good side
yeah he's targeting the pawn in the
center let's see if Jarvis just goes for
like a typical okay wow the pawn has
been grabbed
look at that
okay we have some tricky lines let's see
how well oh Frank has a juicy 850 rating
he was 200 last time I saw him play
Blitz of course rapid is different so
you know he technically looks like the
favorite right now but we don't know
what is Frank doing
he just looked over and he was just
wide-eyed rubbing his hands together
screaming does he know it's his move
he's manifesting and it's all about the
energy that you bring to the game he's
playing the Mind Games
I'm this is good this is what I learned
from boxing as well not about what you
fight it's just how intimidating you can
be mentally
sorry so you're saying it's all mental
unboxing it's not about the quality of
the punches
50 50 but I think one big reason
Michelle like went in so strong is
because before the match she was staring
at me doing all these mind games and it
really made me scared and it worked it
worked very much and I think Frank's
doing the same tactic
uh yeah yeah I think he's he's he's
going he's what happens yeah but see the
difference here Andrea is that and he
did take the pawn by the way with the
with the threat on the F7 Pawn the
difference is you had to look at
Michelle like what if Jarvis just
minimizes the window yeah well then the
plan will all fail just like the fried
liver so we will see
yeah well by the way there's a way that
white could lose I mean queen to H4 or
even Queen to F6 are actual just pure
Checkmate threats
uh Jarvis might get a little bit
concerned about this but any move here
is good fighting for the center
uh just I don't know not like don't go
here wow D5 on the board by Jarvis
hitting the bishop defended by the queen
defending the Knight stopping this very
aggressive he is a principled man he
didn't move his Queen early on
the fact that he saw that he could
interpose stop a threat by getting in
the way is already really good I'm
really worried Frank is kind of a
a one move play or something of a check
and then black is gonna block but maybe
Frank is gonna go Queen here because
that is pretty cheeky is there any way
we can see what Frank is going on about
could we hear him
I think so
let's take a look at his stream we do
have audio
um okay or if okay do I go there and
give a check
oh goodness me goodness gracious me
okay now I see why he's
mixing his hands together
I okay do I just go there
okay boom I go do I go there oh I think
he's gonna try to set up Jarvis I'm
gonna try to meet him early in the game
okay who might go there getting really
excited over this position please
check right there he goes there I did
there he takes there
okay we're gonna go there and give a
check
um he's very excited about this check
it's not gonna do much but but I'm glad
he's excited I called that by the way
um if I do I go there he takes away but
what if Knight F7 is winning the game
the queen do I do that
um I feel it so I do go there okay he
doesn't stop I can't even come here no
don't do that what are you doing
ladies and gentlemen is Gotham chess's
Prodigy student Frank who he actually
coached it's because he's been hanging
out with you okay next he's gonna hang
his
oh my God wait this is actually gonna
work out for Frank yes yes Frank's big
idea why can't I go backwards what is
going on Bring It Back chess.com how do
I how do I go back how do I film the
show is Frank show us Frank I want to
see if he's gonna see it one Queen here
he just has to go backwards he just has
to relax oh he didn't play but he did no
Frank traded the queen he didn't take
the pump
Frank
you know he took a risk and it was a bad
move but it could have paid off but now
that even that it's now it's just oh but
but now he has it again Bishop takes
Pawn Jarvis has to go backwards oh and
he's on the board
sounds like a cheeky sack worked off now
you should be extremely proud you could
say this was all calculated all part of
the Mind Game I I it was it was not
calculated and that's kind of the my my
like my concern with Frank as his coach
is if you leave Frank in a room for two
minutes the room will be on fire
everything in the room will be destroyed
like for no reason he gets super excited
on the fifth move of the game and I'm
like Frank it's move five you know and
he screams and screams and then he gives
away a night
um but honestly Frank is kind of my
favorite now I like I like the energy he
brings I don't care if it's not good
chess
that's true now we could say this is
open I think Frank is going to take the
pawn though which is technically the
best yes technically it's the best even
if he falls for the bait Yep this could
be some GM level play right here
but actually I think for beginners Andre
I don't know you could disagree with me
yeah taking this is what I would prefer
because you go there your Bishop is
going to get trapped and he actually
does take the Knight
I think he would have taken the pawn and
then eventually realized the Knight was
still hanging and just kind of walked
into the best move but so far Frank's
Wild Card energy versus Jarvis's mature
well-experienced chess is working very
well yeah Jarvis is playing like a like
a full-on professional uh just calmly
sitting there head in his hands
um yeah that's like that's chess player
pose wondering why you showed up to play
in the first place and
and
not even think he just
he just Asian it's not a bad move
because he is winning so trading a
bishop for a knight is not bad but you
really don't want to trade the bishop
because look how easily black can create
an attack this is the problem this is he
should have kept his Bishop because
there's I am worried for for a low rated
all black needs to do is develop and
it's gonna be not very easy for Frank to
defend okay he's going on or something
can you please give me the Frank I want
to hear what he's saying yeah let's just
can we just put Frank on the screen we
don't even need to commentate this no
comments let Frank takeover chess.com
really just flies on the wall
please
we asked nicely
boom We Castle up oh goodness Maddie
talked about my pieces I need to
activate my pieces holy okay he sees it
holy
[Music]
six minutes okay okay the Bishops are
coming out let's see if he knows how to
defend I don't really know what that
does right there
what is that movement
movement what is that movement okay okay
I like that he has to touch all the
pieces to realize where he's going
someone has to tell him someone has to
tell him about touch move in chess if
you let's let's bring it back to the
analysis board because it's impossible
to actually commentate and analyze it
because Frank it's just non-stop action
he's like a good British fighter you
know uh he did develop his Knight which
is good
um
and uh he's up two pawns Andrea I mean
like you can't like and all these pawns
are bad these are all isolated Pawn
Islands uh yeah you know he's doing well
I have to say even though you know he's
always talking I actually love hearing
his thought process because it might
look like without Audio Oh my God and a
man has no idea but he knows what he's
doing he sees the Bishops he knows to
develop I think even though he sounds
like a ticking Time Bomb he knows
exactly how to defend this it's like mad
scientist Vibes you know what is he
doing what does he do is he Shadow
visioning Creator clash as he beats up
Frank I mean sorry yeah I mean he's at
this rate he will literally accidentally
beat himself up by the way Jarvis played
everything I showed I mean Jarvis is a
good player and I don't know anything
about Jarvis he has two games played on
his chest.com account and they're
against butts and he beats I think a
1500 baht
so he's clearly not bad at all if listen
okay if this was an open mic match and
Jarvis would your Frank it would be game
over game over yeah
you're right he has been playing perfect
chess and he's very strong he's like
chess a long time since he was a kid he
was even in chess club yeah which is
like the sure sign of of a cool kid like
the alpha of the of the social group
goes to chess club is that how it was at
your school uh yep yeah no we were all
the very cool kids in chess club
yeah too cool because they knew chess is
a gateway for other things like Robotics
and math and exactly at College uh will
Jarvis play H5 or Bishop H3 continuing
the attack all of these ideas if he does
then I have to say Jarvis might be like
Sea Dogs best match like this is very
good positional play if he even
continues with that
because he has a good position but he
doesn't have the resources to fight
White's Advantage White's two pawns are
very good white can go here and start
trading so black has to be a menace and
if Jarvis just plays easy moves like
bringing the Rook or something like that
with no clear plan Frank will start
trading pieces actually can I be honest
I have no clue what Frank is gonna do I
mean I don't think he has stopped
talking how is he not tired why would we
ever mute the Frank
I think just keep Frank going on all day
long
Frank is going to get so exhausted after
this I mean he literally just keeps like
I'm exhausted
like that that's a very big tarnish
okey-dokey hokey dokey composure
composure my dear Frank composure my
dear Frank
this is why they call him Frank the
thing I can really just oh compose do
they actually call them bad I don't know
to go
there boom we go there with the Knight
yep we're gonna go there and put Frozen
that's a good night move
I don't really know we're gonna go there
and we're gonna go put pressure on one
of his Bishops okay okay A little bit of
a cook I don't really know what the
Rooks are doing right now but they are
looking a little bit scary
okay I need to activate my Bishop as
well I do need to activate my Bishop
right here
but you know what we are looking
composed we are looking composed okay
five minutes left on Jarvis's clock five
minutes left on Jarvis's clock
[Music]
right now
why is there a tiger in the woods that's
not its natural habitat yeah that's a
problem
okay he's look he's a Madman talking
nonsense but his play is solid he's the
Finnegan's Bishops nine in the center he
said he needs to connect his Rook so he
sees what he needs to do
by the way I I think C3 is a genius move
because he's gonna provide a building
block
explicitly push this take it just as
long as he doesn't blunder the pawn it's
very it's very easy with these Rooks and
these Bishops they control so much space
to give away a pawn then you give away
another now suddenly you're screaming
that you've lost all your pawns but he's
actually playing quite good like he he's
playing very well given the
circumstances oh that's a really good
move
oh that's a really good move by Jarvis
wow Jarvis is sure putting Frank Under
Pressure this is not easy to defend
yeah Frank is gonna have to use his
pawns and I'm really worried he's gonna
just walk with the Knight and scream a
lot and then lose his Knight no he would
never let the Knight wander in the woods
he knows
it all comes back to the woods when one
is alone in the woods you do not wander
because you might run into Tigers
therefore Frank has figured this out and
he's gonna push his Pawn in defend
yes according to the game clock he's
very even on time we're getting an
action-packed first game this is awesome
because I didn't know how good Jarvis
was going in and I I was right by the
way I know my student he goes for a
night Journey
uh but Jarvis could also make a mistake
here right like he could blunder a fork
I don't know how it would be very hard
to do that actually well maybe we need
to play Rook here for some reason
well with D4 this could be I see this as
an outpost night
it could be a strength
yeah push some pawns get the bishop a
little bit of Trace it's hard for Frank
to move because if he moves this bishop
he's gonna lose this Pawn so he has to
move that pawn then he has to move the
nether Pawn then he has to move his
Bishop so does he know all of that the
good news is it's Jarvis's move and he's
down to three and a half minutes and I
would go to Jarvis's camera but he is
way too calm so uh Rook B5 good move now
will Frank keep going with the Knight I
predicted this this and then losing the
Knight on that square
could we maybe tune in I want to see if
he's gonna push or move the Knight my
guess is he's gonna push the pawn and
he's a well principled player
I I thought that was the cue I thought
that was pretty I thought that was
pretty clear that we do it again
together going to Frank to see his
thought process it's a Disney Channel I
think actually I think his audio is
playing I think we just can't hear it oh
there it is damn it
I have no clue but it's looking
dangerous
um if I go there okay boom I go there
oh what okay okay if I um
okie dokie
okie dokie I go um
okay oh okay I'm gonna go there with the
night for now okay boom we go there we
threaten a pawn that takes that I'll
take
oh oh no I can't take porn there let's
bring it back to the analysis board real
quick because uh um actually oh oh a lot
has happened oh boy
oh boy so the Knight did in fact go
there and Frank said he was threatening
a pawn which he is absolutely not
threatening which is what I predicted
now the bishop sees The Rook but Frank
counters with a bishop attack that's not
a good trade but it's still okay because
white has enough pawns this is crazy
three minutes on the clock is Jarvis
gonna take the Rook
oh boy I I zoned out for a second and
now Frank might be losing a piece
yeah oh oh no now Frank has to make a
decision he has to take this bishop if
he takes that one this bishop comes out
here and the King has no safety you've
got to take this bishop to force the
black Bishop backwards so your King has
light squares and he takes the wrong
bishop and now the bishop can run out
and The Rook can come down and Jarvis
could win this game in the next five
moves
well that's not very optimistic for for
poor Frank I think um you know with the
element of surprise hopefully not
hopefully this game will last more than
five moves
I have full faith full faith I could see
Frank bringing out a bishop and covering
the back rank like will Jarvis realize
that he doesn't have to take the pawn
and he has to move the bishop this is
the best move if he plays Bishop H3 I I
I'm he's gonna win the tournament yeah
like I'm sorry this is fully zoned in he
hasn't moved he has a stoic pose and he
moves the bishop
okay not the move I said so he's still a
a you know very good player but I said
if he finds this move to snuggle the
king and oh that would have been game
over
um now Rook D5 hitting the Knight with
the bishop and The Rook comes down
that's why charles.com gave this a
question mark Rude by the way and that
move is winning on the spot these two
moves are now winning for black because
of the threat on the night and the
attack on the back rank
wow
he is a killer
well oh my goodness
you don't think a move like what Bishop
E3 we survive
well actually I think it's even better
to save the Knight and just go for a run
this is why the bishop on H3 would have
been lethal because the king can't come
up you have to try to suffocate a king
that's trying to escape off of the back
rank I'm not sure Frank is going to see
that he might also he did see it okay I
think
uh counter attack keeping up the
pressure this is even better
wow that's an incredible move but
now Rook F5
hits the bishop and you can't take
because of the pin that's the winning
move Rook F5 setting up an attack while
this Knight is hanging I don't know if
he sees that that's ridiculous that is
if Jarvis sees the pin piece because
otherwise it looks like maybe he's
losing the pawn on ec7 if you don't
realize that you're gonna be threatening
that Bishop in one move it looks like
maybe white could come back a little bit
yeah if he doesn't see that and he's
only got any any and he hangs The Rook
completely he's blundered the roof Come
Back Time Frank the Tank Frank the Tank
this is good I this is what I wanted
this is what I wanted and now Frank
could finally take the pawn and he's
going to but that's not the right move
because then the Knight is kind of
Trapped and he does well that is if your
opponent knows to trap the Knight maybe
the night will roam free through the
forest yes the massive comeback now and
King takes Pawn on the board now now
it's impossible to Checkmate but the
Rook is going to take a bunch of Pawns
here it's not over this is anybody's
game this Knight has no way out no way
out
I don't know Frank will find a way I
just somehow something tells me he's
gonna figure it out oh that is that's a
good move and now if the bishop goes to
D5 Knight takes Bishop easy and we go to
a rook end game everybody's favorite
subject beginners playing Rook end games
literally like toddlers in the kitchen
Bishop D3 is a good move oh my goodness
Andrea Rook D1 Bishop here Rook gives a
check and then Checkmate on the back
rank oh please no
this is oh please no
it might happen
I also like that Frank has a little bit
of extra time time pressure is really
Jarvis has been a very solid
solid player but he is getting under a
minute soon
yeah this is this is craziness
can we um maybe tune in to hear what uh
if Frank is gonna see this tricky back
rank let's let's listen to Frank he's a
little behind us but let's get let's get
him on audio
oh no
okay okie dokie okie dokie oh how do I
play out of this position I go there he
can win a pawn
um okay okay do I go there mate okay
boom I go
oh my goodness he's trying to escape but
he can't go there then I go there do I
just look for a pawn right here I don't
know what we're trying to do he's gonna
go there yeah I can't say he sees your
five head ELO plan but
I can't go there uh process of
elimination mate we're gonna go
I just understand beginner games yeah
let's bring it back to the analysis
where Jarvis didn't uh Jarvis did not
play the most critical move Bishop to E4
would have prevented the king from
escaping so it would have been
impossible for The Rook to come down uh
but you know end games are hard like in
the end game you know you're gonna
you're gonna do this and uh instead of
playing uh you know the move that's
supposed to restrict the king but Andrea
they each have a minute I mean this is
like well Bishop C2 was just played
looks like it's gonna happen oh that's
not a good end game move by Frank gonna
happen
Jarvis gotta just take the pawn he just
takes the pawn and the knight's still
stuck
Jarvis has to take oh on the board by
the way he he's preventing the king from
escaping nice he's coming back to that
winning plan he's trying to get that
back rank mate at some point oh Frank is
not doing his Rook anymore the thing is
that Knight is never gonna go anywhere
and that King can take that pawn at any
time so Jarvis is taking his time he's
gonna squeeze him like a snake
yeah and Frank is down 20 seconds Frank
is 50 50 seconds on the clock he plays
A4 because he does not know what else to
do if Jarvis just stays composed and
he's taking the pawns oh my goodness and
he could just go win these pawns next 98
Check Yes I knew that Frank was going to
do that but oh no
winning but I mean this actually could
be a winning end game and he snatches it
he's winning Frank is up three pawns but
does he know how to win this or is he
just going to push oh my goodness if he
doesn't get his King off the back rank
oh King G4 King oh my goodness there's a
mate if Frank doesn't bring his King up
he might get checkmated King G4 is a
fork though pushing it sometimes he's
panicking
the king is coming okay oh Jarvis has to
go right here to prevent the king from
escaping and then Checkmate but that's
the only way he can might get baited by
the check though rookie seven game over
it's a rook trade it's a rook trade for
Frank wow
wow
and just push the F Pawn that that's
there's a pawn there Frank you can't
hey he's clicking them one by one and
eventually he'll realize the f-pawn yes
okay Pace them all okay like the king
but he's he's getting in over there
oh my goodness what a battle this has
been and it's not over yet but six pawns
versus three oh the Breakthrough by
fight very classic very classy yeah this
is why when I was owning chess my dad
said as a beginner all you need to know
is your end game you just forced your
opponent to trade and if you know how to
win an end game you're set and Jarvis
had to go to E5 there he had to get in
the Square if you're watching this as a
chess beginner learn what the square is
it was still losing but now Frank is
getting a queen Andrea the only thing
remaining will there be a stalemate
I don't know Frank is known for his
viral clippable moments so I really
based on his play so far don't know but
he has played a beautiful tricky game
yes it's been
back and forth action uh there's this
the thing is Jarvis can move the the
pawn
it's almost a Salesman knows what he's
doing he's gonna try to find Andrea
Andrea there's a stalemate coming Pawn
here take King G4 he pushes and it's a
stalemate oh my goodness well you you
clearly you I'm sure you taught Frank
about stalemate no okay
oh this I blame you for all of this this
is
oh my goodness
Andrea you
just do the con oh God welcome to pod
Champs ladies and gentlemen
this is re this is real right this I
don't know if you're setting me up or
something I I genuinely can't tell I
think this is real
I'm I'm that's I am Wild
um all I have to say is if I was Frank's
coach we would have had a mate
let's go see Frank's reaction oh how did
I not see that oh you're taking them
you're taking the mick oh oh I didn't
see the snow okay this is real it wasn't
afraid oh you're kidding me you're
kidding me
no I didn't see the stalemate
I didn't see it
oh yeah it sounds like a broken man oh
you're taking the neck you're taking the
mick okay all right well after our very
first game welcome to pog Champs by the
way if you're not watching that is how
we start off POG champs this is what POG
Champs is about making your chess
teachers suffer oh wow I yeah you know
I'm not I'm not doing this in a way that
I'm cheering for anybody to lose but it
like I I just had a feeling it was
coming after the first game it's half
half friendly reminder they play two
games you get a game with white in the
game with black it's not a knockout it's
a round robin Everybody Plays everybody
so we're gonna have a game coming up
here in a moment we're not going to any
break
um now Jarvis gets the white pieces
Frank gets the black pieces
where it's dude Jarvis played on and set
that up and it worked so even more
respect to Jarvis oh tremendous respect
to Jarvis who also
like I didn't know if he was a total
beginner I mean I would estimate his
strength at 6 700 easily and if he just
fills in a few more gaps in the
knowledge he's a 8 900 rated player he
really really fought he was outplayed it
was a very tense game but that's life
Frank actually raised his accuracy
throughout that game by like 15 it went
from 60 to 76 and then he still made it
and as far as I'm concerned he loses 50
of the accuracy right there
um
wow
amidst the Frank chaos he had some very
brilliant moments and they just like
that sack that made no sense but then it
worked out for him I don't even know how
that night got out in that end game but
that was a crazy game that was so well
done how he timed the night jump traded
down did everything right
the way you prevent that from happening
you need to always try to make sure that
the opponent has a legal move and he had
two minutes to do that right you can
teach that to him his next lesson I
tried he doesn't really listen it's okay
uh you know what um I'm curious to see
how Jarvis plays his second game uh what
opening he's going to play uh I I'm
trying to I think I have it here and um
Jarvis plays E4 and Frank's been playing
the French is this you did you did you
uh teach me first of all it's my sister
plays the French not me I would never
teach the French
um but I also taught him nothing because
I I don't think he was very interested
in lessons he just wanted to wing it and
do his thing which he's he's sure doing
yeah Knight C3 is a completely
reasonable move I don't know if Jarvis
is trying to play a Vienna or if this is
just like you know because sometimes you
learn the Vienna so you think everything
is a Vienna you know you get a hammer
you think everything is a nail uh but
two nights in the center and two Pawns
in the center against most openings is a
good strategy I've been I have a feeling
he's going to take her push
yeah that's also right now Frank is just
out of any known stuff like they're just
gonna have to play a chess game
um I would love to hear some opening
commentary by Frank because I don't know
how it's the third move and just it
looks like something crazy is about to
happen already by the way Jarvis did not
react whatsoever
that's true wait there was no
celebratory nothing like yeah he got
stalemated down a queen in three pawns
and he was just like
well that's how you know he's very zoned
in
yeah I mean that's I guess that's why he
was a boxer bought in the ring exactly
he can handle a little stalemate
um yeah I've never seen such a calm
player are we gonna listen in on Frank's
opening thoughts is that our is that our
planner along all right let's see what
Frank has to say
to do that I'm happy with that I'm a
happy duck I'm a happy duck I'm a very
happy duck I'm a very very happy duck
yes the analogies I just don't know
where it's [__] right now okay we're
good we're cooking there's even an
analogy you just identifies as a duck I
guess yeah he's a happy duck like what
can I say
[Music]
is cooking himself
um okay he just frantically clicks the
clicking I go
um oh goodness gracious me
goodness gracious me okay okay I want do
I just take do I just okay let's bring
this back to the analysis board and show
why what Frank is doing is kind of wrong
uh and I've actually told him this as
well but I'll have to tell him and this
is just kind of a general beginner
lesson uh if you don't have a good
reason to trade a bishop for a night
don't do it so Bishop here there is no
reason to make that move
uh gotta respect the bishop pair and
like maybe right you're damaging the
structure but white can just take and he
might even blunder his Rook if he's not
yeah that's a very scary sniper
so
yeah I mean and that's what he did oh
goodness he took so quick
he didn't even think about it he didn't
even reflect
Jarvis is so good
oh my goodness
I wonder when Jarvis will say his first
word
I bet you he's just gonna log off we're
not even gonna get to interview him if
he wins oh my goodness he is sensitive
Jarvis is insane he's playing very well
and I mean yeah from what I've seen from
Jarvis the amount of projects he can
handle I know when he does something he
does it full-fledgingly and his chest is
great and that's exactly what I expected
but Frank the wild card once again you
know last game he had a Checkmate turned
into a stalemate maybe this game the
loss will turn into a win
I don't know how Frank is going to make
a comeback in this game because he is
losing this Rook for absolutely nothing
like sometimes The Rook is getting
trapped and you get the bishop
he's gonna have to push his Pawn to trap
the bishop that weakens his King I don't
know and Jarvis doesn't even have to
take the Rook he could go here he could
even trade the queens and then take like
his position is incredible he of course
could just take the Rook
um so we're gonna see how Jarvis
maintains a winning position Frank had a
winning position last game maintained it
and then threw it all away in one move
that's what beginner chess is all about
very curious to see how Jarvis handles
Jarvis wins this game his estimated ELO
is like easily 900 8 900 and he took he
didn't even wow yeah
yep waiting to take the Rook
sign that shows Advanced chess
and it would have been slightly better
to take with the bishop just to get the
bishop out rather than have a pawn there
but whatever right like it's okay and
he's gonna go here and uh
yeah no I I have a feeling Jarvis is
gonna be a very solid player
oh to his credit Frank found this
the problem is if now Frank dedicates
the whole game to getting this bishop
he's going to get obliterated because
Queen H5 is a fork you're gonna win this
yeah Queen H5 is already absolutely
lethal
and Jarvis might not see it but that's a
very common beginner check
and
he's just gonna just bludgeon this
position I mean typically I'm always
telling my students don't go for these
Queen moves not in the beginning but
this is just this is game over and
Jarvis hasn't been missing so I won't be
surprised if he finds this check
yeah you never want to play Queen H5
against the fully equipped Army because
the queen on her own like will just get
booted but this is so this is really bad
this is like the loan shark coming to
collect you've got absolutely nothing
here he doesn't see it that happens he's
still completely winning the principles
yep and he's very principled player
yeah like one left on his own he does
not burn the house down Frank does and
also his neighbor's house like that's
the difference I I formulate to Frank
with that
yeah I mean I mean three is just easy
now we see the advantage of having the
bishop here you can Castle
um hey yeah that's really good it means
there's a chance for Frank the Queen's
not coming in the king is
safe for a little bit longer this is
making me optimistic
Queen E7 is a nice move from Frank by
the way uh he can trap the bishop by
going there after he moves the Knight so
Jarvis can't fall asleep at the wheel
here he's gotta he's gotta cause some
problems or he's gonna lose the bishop
and then Frank is actually back in the
game uh what do you think Andrea just
Bishop E2 and Castle or
yeah I mean Jarvis seems so principled
like nothing he's he's up material he's
gonna develop he's gonna castle and I
have a feeling he's just gonna slowly
squeeze the win he doesn't really care
about that Bishop he doesn't need it
at the same time I think he's creative
enough to find a way out I don't know
how I don't know how he's gonna do it
but I kind of trust him I like to
because at the very least you want to
give away the bishop for the pawn so
when your Bishop gets trapped right you
don't lose it for nothing it's called
the Desperado
you lose the bishop for the pawn because
you were going to lose it for free uh
I didn't have Frank animal Bingo on my
on my list today but he named a tiger he
named a duck
maybe maybe we tuned back into Frank oh
interesting move he's trying to make the
queen happen yeah he tried to do it but
now there's this ridiculous Haymaker
does Frank see it okay tune in let's
tune in this is this is a critical
moment
oh my God this is crazy yeah Queen
before it could be another comeback he
got some tunnel vision there now we're
tuning in um okay boom we go there then
I can go there and give a check okay
okay if I go okay boom I go there give a
check
okie dokie okie dokie okay boom I go
there give a check he can only move
there then I go there give a chance you
see it he says the check he doesn't see
the fort
in the forest yeah like a duck in the
savannah
do I go oh no
oh do I just okay boom I okay I think
he's gonna see it I give a check there
right
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
let go of the mouse damn it
oh let go of the mouse just just do it
or don't do it I don't even know who
you're cheering for I just I want to see
good chess oh he stabbed himself
he's His Own Worst Enemy
hokey dokey okey dokey we give a check
that okay he did it's on the board he
did it let's bring it back all right
let's bring it back
oh but I just sees it now Andrea does he
see the Knight is hanging I think so I
think so oh that's crazy stuff I mean oh
Queen D2 this kind of seems to be the
reoccurring theme with Frank's chest he
doesn't see the full plan but he just
kind of walks into these tactics that
end up working for him yes it happened
in the beginning he really is he he
thought that Jarvis's only move was
moving the King which is a common
mistake beginners make like they don't
think about the blocks he might think
that he's kind of cooked here and
whatever he takes he's just unhappy
trading the Queens would be and he's
always found it oh the comeback The
Comeback is beginning my goodness
oh wow
now Frank's only down an exchange and
that Bishop is trapped so this could be
anybody's game oh and yeah Jarvis has to
really really just calm down and Castle
his King see if he had just stuck to
that this and this it would have been
good this principles yeah but then I
think he got a little greedy he was like
wait a minute I've got this queen idea
which he could have played last move
and yeah chess is a brutal game it's all
about taking your opportunities
I have to say the fact that he's still
taking it so seriously even when he's up
a whole Rook look for winning plans
I mean Jarvis is a
D he is and I wouldn't be surprised if
his next move is here and here like
Jarvis is an exceptional player I mean
he he started this game red hot
so I mean I'm cheering for both players
I'm I'm like uh I'm like the the guy at
the football match that has two jerseys
on one on top of the other and then like
when Frank is doing well I have the
Frank Jersey then I put the Jarvis
Jersey on
here I'm I'm a little worried that Frank
is going to misplaces Queen
um not necessarily give it away but not
give it a lot of space to move hopefully
there's no boats as Gambit's coming
that's that there you go okay solid
Queen in the center great Queen in the
center now Jarvis just has to
Jarvis nice and easy don't chase the
queen
don't chase the quick just get the
bishop and castle
get the bishop and Castle you're gonna
be great once you Castle game is going
to open up it's gonna be so much easier
I mean there's not much many other plans
to distract him so following like a
normal process of elimination I think
it's very logical for Jarvis to Castle
here
what else could he do I guess he could
try to save his Bishop maybe like a
bishop G7 eventually take it to H6
yeah I could see that uh I could see him
try to go after the queen which is very
easy to get tunnel vision Queen C3 is
not a bad move trying to trade the queen
but
Travis the finger versus Frank the Tank
that's very accurate yeah Jarvis got a
philosopher vibe there we go Rook C1 not
a bad move activating the pieces
he has a lot of different ideas I do
like that he is a creative player
doesn't always go straight just for the
principles even though he's been playing
very solid if Frank plays the move Ponte
F5 I am disconnecting from the broadcast
like y'all can y'all get a substitute I
I will not commentate the games if Frank
loses his Queen I will gladly take it on
sounds like it would be my Prodigy
student he's got
okay that's a check he gave a check just
because he could
but now it's you know you gotta have
another game plan what is Jarvis gonna
do here
Yep this is uh one of my main advice to
beginners even though you have a check
doesn't mean you need to do it you feel
accomplished you get to say the word
check you make eye contact with the
appointment opponent but then after
there's not much
uh
now Knight to D4 is a nice move from
from Frank continuing the attack or
Frank could play Bishop here and Castle
okay now Jarvis just has to go he just
has to Castle it's game on if he castles
now both sides are finally getting their
King out of the middle of the board no
they're not no they're not not yet they
don't say it stop it
Frank is gonna go I mean Jarvis is gonna
play here or something like I oh my
goodness
they will I don't know like a tiger in
the forest
oh what is what Jarvis is just
forgetting about castling yeah I don't
know he seems a little bit stumped I
think probably what happened also if
he's getting in his own head because he
started with that Rook then he made a
slight blunder and he's been slowing
down so another part of this is oh wow
okay you know what Kings might stay in
the center but depends depends where the
Queen's gonna go uh Andrea did he castle
in the last game Jarvis
you know that game is kind of a blur I
have to say I'm sure he knows oh no he
wasn't allowed to Castle remember
because Frank he attacked his piece and
then he took with his King
oh you're right there was no no chance
of castling ever happening in that game
okay but see Frank didn't take the dark
squares so there's hope Castle
wait are you I don't even think it's
good here are you telling me that Jarvis
is playing like 800 level chess without
knowing the rules he doesn't know that
you can Castle in this position I'm sure
he knows he was in chess club as a kid
surely he remembers
the castle I guess we really don't know
because he didn't take any coaching so
nobody knows we'll find out I honestly
this is a critical moment to find out
oh okay I don't I don't think what the f
is this man cooking in a matchup against
an 800 radio player and he doesn't even
know the damn rules well well maybe Rook
F1 is better than Castle in this
position here it's nice it ain't it
never moved okay oh my goodness let's
hear it can we hear Frank
and when I hear him cooking that's crazy
minutes are now left on Jarvis o'clock
that's how we're doing it baby that's
how we're doing it okay
okay I go boom I go oh boy getting
distracted neither sides are gonna
Castle now yeah okay boom okay we've
been upon there we also want to hear
Jarvis but he doesn't speak right
[Music]
okay we're just gonna go
do I just take a free porn I wanna take
a free porn we're not threatened
nothing's being threatened right we just
take that that can go there
um could he trap my queen maybe good
questions
okay we're gonna go boom we're gonna go
there next
okey dokey yeah we're gonna go take a
pawn next all right you're right you're
right uh yeah do I go there oh I want to
go there I do want to go should we tune
in on Jarvis and see what he's thinking
we're just gonna tell you maybe but what
is he thinking okay can we can we can we
just put the camera on Jarvis real quick
producers got a lot going on and I think
Jarvis doesn't do it I've drawn it back
a little bit let's all right let's let's
go back to the analysis what a few
things have happened and then maybe we
can pop in on Jarvis uh so Frank played
uh Queen takes Pawn
and Jarvis had to attack the king while
it was still in the center but Frank has
castled and
Jarvis has lost his Advantage because
he's opening the center of the board
he's up a little bit of material
or maybe it's like equal now that his
his pawns have lost uh he's lost a
couple pawns yeah finally the
long-awaited Jarvis tune in yes let's
tune in on Jarvis Let's Hear His
Thoughts
ah yes
good one
what's up everybody be quiet
profound stuff profound stuff from
Professor I think he's gonna win it all
I think I I I love that a bit
controversial for my taste for the first
you know match of the day but but uh I
wish he would have kept that to himself
but sounds like he's cooking
it makes sense it definitely makes sense
um okay back to the big screen massive
developments both players nearly
identical on the clock Frank has gobbled
up a couple of Pawns Jarvis is fading a
little bit he started very strong
and
wanna Rook but didn't Castle lost his
Knight and now it's a very like he the
only chance that Jarvis has
attacking Frank or else Frank will go
here
and here and apparently now oh rookie
rookie
Jarvis has great instincts and a great
thought process I think he just needs
like one chess lesson to learn the
basics and learn about castling and then
he could really win this whole thing
yeah seriously he learns about castling
though
Frank is winning the king now has to
start moving if you block with the
bishop the Knight comes in
and it's bad news
yeah I think Jarvis just faded a bit oh
goodness for the king walk
well
yeah this is getting very tricky but
that's only if
you excuse all these four
correct and Frank might just try to give
a check and then trade the queen
remember Frank is
subtlety is not necessarily the strong
suit of an 800 not just Frank like
Knight D4 is a hard move taking away
squares and opening the bishop but if he
plays Knight D4 I think Frank will win
the game he plays Queen B3 I have no
idea
I don't know
also Frank's accuracy has skyrocketed up
to 84 percent
oh wow we don't need to see what Frank
is thinking [__] Knight to D4 wow and I
think he's founded Andre I think we
might be looking at the last few moves
here okay this would actually be insane
he has to make a block he has to make a
block oh do I want to go there though do
I want to go there
um okay we'll go okay boom we'll go
there next
hokey dokey we'll go boom there next all
right all right yeah we're gonna go
there we're gonna defend that pawn some
more that takes her I'll just take there
uh nothing threatening my queen right
now oh composure Frank composure is my
best friend
okay we're currently winning a trade-off
right here okay boom I go there he takes
and I take then he takes then I'll take
okay having said all of this amazing
stuff that he just did about the night
move
I don't know if he's looking
that that's the thing he does these
amazing moves he doesn't see the winning
blend but then he stumbles into it so
just like like a little lost toddler
stumbling through the woods that just
somehow keeps surviving but I think like
if he sees this bishop A4 this is game
over
yeah Bishop A4 is
looking at the wrong Pawn but guys he
clicks them all so don't worry
this is Checkmate on the board this is
Queen B3 Queen B2
and then you have like a you give them
the Rook you sack the rook and then it's
Gigi
sorry how I'm actually trying to find
the wait
did I attack The Rook yes no no you
don't attack The Rook it's Queen B3 and
then it's the bishop coming in but I
mean Frank's only got 90 seconds I don't
know Frank's about to take this pawn and
like lose the game I mean really the POG
Champs he found Bishop before
I was thinking Stack The Rook for white
my bad you're talking about the black
wait I just realized something in all of
my analysis Queen C7 is Checkmate if
Frank doesn't give a check right now
he's going to lose
if he plays Queen B3 Queen C7 is made oh
my God
oh my God Checkmate is on the board we
had this stalemate he's gonna learn from
his mistakes and be very cautious he's
keeping his composure so this is just a
minute on the clock oh my God
I'm gonna be sick
uh he's he's leaning in closer to the
screen which I think means he sees it
now the good news is this is a check and
it wins a rook that's the good news
well done so far we're safe so far we're
safe yes he's going to take the rook and
as long as Jarvis takes with this Rook
he will have winning chances so Jarvis
can still win this game with one minute
on the clock it is anybody's game as far
as I'm concerned this is crazy
but Jarvis has to go here he can't
really be brave and look forward there's
not a lot of great options for his King
it looks very uncomfortable position to
play very uncomfortable but he has no
choice yeah and he's only got 40 seconds
Jarvis he's got to make a move oh
he's forced to take with the King here
okay he could walk over and still but
that's tough okay there's no more made
on C7 now Frank just has to bring in the
Army he might accidentally open just if
if King here it's mate by the way
oh Queen teacher was made on the board
what
oh God oh God come on Frank take this
one home Frank could also go here and
hang his Queen like it Queen C2
he's cooking he's cooking I think this
is it on the board and he's won it Queen
C2 mate okay Frank delivers the kiss of
death
and I think but after that stalemate I
needed to see him finish
he moves there I'll give a check he
moves there I'll give a check okay now
I'm gonna go
um now we'll go boom we'll go there okey
dokey we're gonna go oh wait is that me
it's that me okay
oh yes
she was literally a miniature Han
that's how he cooks
come on and the house
he played so well and this shit's so
unfortunate that's how I roll baby he's
still going imagine losing to this guy
and soon again oh my goodness well you
heard it here first ladies and gentlemen
Frank the chess Prodigy is a mixture of
Hans demon and Austin Powers and he gets
the first win of pogchamps five in a
ridiculous back and forth affair with
the mysterious Jarvis Jarvis coming in
with an unclear chess pedigree and it
was very very quality chess there for an
hour uh I am that was awesome don't
sleep on Jarvis I'm gonna see if he
wants like a principal chess lesson
because I think once he learns about he
learns about castling these next few
games aren't gonna go like this
no they're not and I mean he's he's got
nothing to that was that was amazing I
mean what what more can you say uh that
was what a what a fight that was
um
let's take a look at the group standings
obviously we've just had one match
finish so who knows who knows it could
be a surprise yeah we might have a
surprise Frank Frank with three points
no way yep Frank uh getting a win in
regulation time so they never went to a
tie break so he's got three points
winning one and a half in the best of
two rapid
oh my goodness I'm sweating those games
were so stressful what a showing from
Jarvis he is not going to be easy to
beat for anybody in this group and Frank
I mean those
that was wild
um I think
I have just been informed that we are
going to get Frank
for an interview so if you thought that
his cutaways were great we about to see
him live bring your volume down just a
little bit sorry sorry I didn't mean to
cut you off yeah I was supposed to do
the address bring the volume down and
you know
Maiden one let's go we'll be right back
after this break we'll be right back is
that what you wanted
yeah I think so
I told them to bring their volume down
yeah well this is not as powerful when
they still leave us we go yeah we're
supposed to do the break now bye
[Music]
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
thank you
still potentially be stalemate but no
Ludwig has no mercy literally 50 wait oh
there was increment I didn't realize
there was increment yes there's a two
second increments so three minutes plus
two second increment he has now
collected a lot of time went all the way
up
[Music]
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm gonna say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chest.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as you're until it stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
two one here we go
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
POG Champs 5 we are joined not just by
Frank but also by Jarvis what an epic
first matchup Frank I'd like to start
with you
how did that match go according to your
expectations did anything surprise you
how are you feeling right now getting
the first win of pogchamps five
well I'm a I'm a happy duck I'm a very
I'm a happy man uh well I was I was I
was a little bit scared because you know
I'm I'm just scared I'm just a very
scared man
um but not normally but well it was like
it was I was very I was happy I mean the
stalemate was bad but um you know what I
recovered I did recover that's always
always good to see nice recovery from
positions right yeah and you started
game two like in a in a tough spot and
you came back from The Rook down so you
did recover Frank before I let Andrea
ask a question would you rather be a
happy duck or the Tiger in the woods
oh oh oh that's a difficult one oh
that's a very you see ducks can Splash
about on the water but then it was it
tight tighter in the wood yeah but then
tigers are like they're very sneaky you
know I'd be a tiger they're very sneaky
in the woods I would like to be yeah
they're really quiet and composed pretty
much what the whole strategy was I think
it worked very well
yeah Jarvis speaking of quiet uncomposed
uh
you're being very humble it was a great
I'm like I'm very genuine uh I I had no
game plan this is the second game of
chess I played uh as a huge against a
human and like since uh in like 17 years
when I was 13 in the like uh chess club
in my middle school
and I I mean so I just found out Frank
is 17 so I'm feeling pretty good
yeah Frank didn't exist the last time
you played a chess game that that really
as well when you were in China the
beauty of Chess when you were in chess
club was it cool or not cool
not cool not cool but neither was I so
it worked out
I'm asking because I feel like you know
the whole culture has shifted now now
it's like weird oh yeah like a teenager
doesn't play chess which is which is
awesome oh that's funny yeah I it it
definitely was it was a bunch of nerds
and band geeks
you know uh uh we definitely weren't
cool but it felt cool to play like bug
house at the like science lab
that was a good time
and buckhouse is a very Andre have you
played Bug House
of course I have played bug house I've
been playing chess since I was six
almost an insult Bunkhouse is the Op
game yeah Bug House is a team chess so
you capture yes and then you give it to
your partner maybe you guys will be a
bug house team one day Frankie I do have
a question for you guys so we have a
very interesting background here we have
Jarvis who just flexed on us he hasn't
played a game of chess in many years
I lost they're clearly not a flame
you're better than 80 of the viewers by
the way yeah
nervous there's people who have been
training for this every day and they're
still 200 so it is a flex you should be
proud however you know lessons always go
a long way and then we have Frank I'm
gonna I'm gonna practice I promise that
was my question exactly you guys plan to
take any chess lessons after today's
games maybe you know brush up on
stalemate or you know castling or just
some principles
uh can I just say that I am aware that I
could have cat at any point that I could
have castled kingside or queen side I
made a deliberate decision not to it was
wrong but it was a choice it was uh I
misjudged the situation I misjudging
yeah because we were wondering you were
playing Sensational chess for the first
like 10 or 15 moves of game two your
average your accuracy was over 90 and I
was wondering if you were doing that
without even knowing the full rules of
the game I was like there's no way but I
played The Rook move instead of castling
so but uh yeah no The Rook move instead
of castling was on purpose because I
thought
thought wrong I thought wrong about my
position I think my biggest weakness and
why I need coaching and stuff is a lot
of uh a lot of its muscle memory and
then just like reasoning in the moment
but I don't genuinely I like don't know
what good moves are or what like like uh
how do I put it
like I sometimes I'm not sure
like what I decided trying to do I don't
know how to just I'm like I like the
reasoning between two things other than
like looking ahead as many moves as I
can but you know like General strategy
that that's something I don't have is
General strategy I'm like try to control
the center of the board open things up
but I don't know I don't know many
openings I don't know many like you know
how things are supposed to play out so
I'm just like winging it you know
lucky for you we have a lot of amazing
chess streamers and coaches and they
will take you through the principles but
that makes total sense
yeah and speaking of which we all
struggle with that so uh like at
whatever level you are it doesn't matter
you're always going to struggle to
really truly determine what's a good
move what's a good plan it's gradual
Improvement uh Jarvis you had a
fantastic performance for having not
played chess since Frank was uh
potentially like still you know
developing into a into a a baby or like
I don't know maybe a couple of months
old uh it was an excellent showing from
you thank you so much for being our
Opening match Frank congratulations
thanks so much for having me congrats to
Frank congrats well deserved
thank you Jarvis
we will let you guys go thank you so
much for for joining uh regardless of
the result and we will see you both back
for your second matches look at this
bye guys
hi guys talk to you later
we are looking ahead now for a match
that is starting in this is gonna be a
good one I'm very excited for this
I am very invested in actually both of
these players
I don't know if chat heard that but I
just heard a very British how do I leave
um in the background it was so composed
that never seen Frank like that I relate
I'm the same as soon as I'm off my
stream I'm like oh hello adult
uh Andrea was saying you were saying
in the next match so you have daily dose
of Internet obviously it doesn't make
videos about his own personality he has
these amazing viral videos but he is
such an interesting character of course
very smart guy who loves chess I've
never seen him play but every time I run
into him he's always talking about Chess
how he wants to play in POG Champs and
it looks like it's finally happening
um and we have actually a very similar
story with Gastly he is a huge American
producer and DJ plays festivals he just
finished six months of touring and he
has recently fallen in love with chess
and just started grinding and grinding
he's reached like 700 in literally maybe
a few months
um so two people who Tess has nothing to
do with what they do but they just love
the game and they're just doing this
because they love the game and I think
that's awesome
yeah I speaking I think we have uh
player cards I don't know if we're if
we're going oh no we're going to the uh
we're going to the Gastly uh
ghastly stream look at that nice I think
this is one of his first time streaming
in a while he's never done a chess
stream so nice if you get a new look
he's got the botas board
he's got the purple color I didn't even
teach him that he is my student but I
guess he did that on his own
no that's uh that that I mean actually I
also have a purple board the the board
that I'm currently uh you know supposed
to put on the big screen here is purple
what is with the purple board we have
purple board Mr Gotham we sent you our
merch you know that one right behind me
I never actually no I saw a photo of
your dog playing on it but may I ask
where it's in your house
you set it up it's right it's right here
on the floor
no there's like a nice little like table
off to the side in my room yeah yeah
yeah I just I never see it so you know
mine's like on the wall behind me you
didn't paint you didn't pay me to
promote it you paid
yeah okay gotcha I mean I don't know if
we can afford you but we'll try you
probably probably not but get the bow
test merch is it still for sale uh of
course yes or
boats has merch until my chessboard
comes out that's why okay actually just
save for my chessboard oh yeah you know
no free promo from Gotham medals all
right sorry yes
yeah
um I think we have a chess match coming
up soon by the way you were giving
Insight daily dose of Internet is in an
undisclosed location and he's like does
he have internet where is he
very unsure if he was gonna make it to
his game oh I know he's been traveling
in Norway and a lot of our players
actually are kind of traveling around
the world like Ginny who we're gonna see
um but I'm glad that he found a setup to
play his chess game and he has really
the best backdrop ever
also the air in Norway is better for
chess right that's that's what that's
where Magnus gets his Advantage look at
look at that wow he's in New York City
oh wow that's those are that's
incredible he's in he's in a Manhattan
corporate building that's another thing
about it this actually might be one of
daily dose's first like regular gaming
streams on Twitch as well this is a
historic day
yeah I don't know if he knows he's on um
the camera though
uh games are starting soon hopefully
he's on chess.com and he knows that
we're starting the daily dose of
Internet he knows everything
this is your daily dose of Internet
um I think I have the game up
if not
they're gonna have to refresh it for me
I have to say these guys kind of look
like they could be brothers or something
they have very similar features
do they yeah do they not look kind of
related to you I don't know no no they
just look like dudes I don't know do
they do white dudes with brown hair same
haircut could be brothers to me wow
daily dose with the bird the bird
opening okay
look at him going with that F4 does he
know the follow look at wow okay I like
it there's a little exotic yeah they
chose this himself because they did not
take lessons so daily dose of creative
men
daily dose is a great look at that
that's a dangerous opening to play okay
now he goes back to D4 the good news is
his accuracy over three moves is 99.8
but that's not really saying too much
um it's the opening
and yeah Gastly is a tough one
yeah we so I did a chess lesson with
Gastly and his principles were very
strong we didn't really get to the
opening
um which is now I'm gonna find this out
today but he does like his he calls it
his fettuccine Bishop so I see he's
doing the fettuccine
I just came back from Italy and I gotta
tell you my favorite accent I mean my
goodness the way they say thank you
grazia every letter pronounced it was it
was incredible
um I think that's the next language I'm
gonna learn so oh this is look at his
opening this is amazing yeah everything
developed this is I think this is going
to be a high level one of our most high
level games of today that's my
prediction
I don't know a thing about daily dose I
checked his chest.com account before the
event and he hadn't played a game since
2022 which is not as impressive as
Jarvis who hasn't played a chess game in
nearly 20 years or so he says
yeah he's probably gone there's no way
there's no way he didn't play one game
the man who signed up for a boxing match
I bet you he prepared a little bit
but I see not enough for Frank
uh now now let's see this is the middle
game White's got the two Bishops Black's
got a good setup okay C4 uh that's
considered a mistake because the pawn is
a bit weak for this level it's not
really a mistake
uh
but I think maybe he wants to go here
now what is gasly gonna play night here
Pawn here okay good thief yeah yeah I
have to say I've never played the bird
and anytime I'm teaching someone who's
new to chess I just say don't push your
f-pawns then you're a king and daily
dose has those holes around his King are
you concerned at all about this
yes but I'm not concerned because I'm
not his coach right because you were his
coach and no no no didn't I wait wait
daily dose is playing white right
yes oh I I apologies I thought you you
guys
because they look so similar that's what
I was saying see yeah oh yeah yeah no no
I just I thought I thought well I
thought you were like friendly with with
uh we've talked about Chess a lot
because every time he comes into town he
lets he tells me he's like I would love
to play Pocket someday and I didn't know
it was happening so I was very excited
but I had never actually taught him
chess but oh okay I'd be happy to
so the problem with uh with daily dose
is right now is that he's kind of just
utilizing what he has he's already moved
a couple of these pawns a lot he's
moving the bishop multiple times and
black is just gonna go here and slowly
develop the position great and then if
he plays B6
I'm I'll be really impressed if he plays
Pawn to B6
or Knight H5
yes I don't know if it'd be possible but
I would love to have a little bit of
Open Mic action from both of our players
here just to hear what they're thinking
even in this layout but his daily dose
has been giving us some commentary and I
have to say I have yet to hear daily
dose chess commentary
commentated everything on the internet
not chess yeah are we gonna pop into the
daily dose uh
stream real quick
I don't I guess we're just waiting
we ask and then they go
I'm gonna get some space in here so I'm
gonna do this
uh-huh
it does just so you're aware everybody
it doesn't show that on his screen I
have no idea who's even commentating
over this
me it's us we were friends
friends we went on a hike together we
were best friends we've done so much I'm
so I went to a vegan restaurant for him
because he's vegan oh my goodness vegan
in 2023. very aggressive
Andrea you're gonna get canceled by the
end of broadcast one I don't know if
that's the smart move but they know it
it's all they have like the same the
vegans aren't real I mean oh my goodness
all right okay all right okay let's
bring it back to the analysis board he
let's not expose every element of daily
dose's life
um no no he's a very proud vegan he
cares about the animals I never said
that he wasn't I just okay oh by the way
by the way his opponent just played this
this is very bad news this could get
there are two forks being threat what do
you call a double Fork
I don't know a double Fork I don't know
a double whammy oh if if we showed this
move to Frank he would have a heart
attack oh I'm going there and then I've
got Bishop takes pawn and I'm dating the
king and the Rook oh my goodness yeah
Bishop takes right how much do you think
I'd have to ask nicely for chesscom to
let Frank commentate just one game one
of them easily easily if I were to just
disappear and Frank takes my spot I
might not even tell anyone but I think
that's what I want by the end Frank
needs a cameo that's what he needs can
you imagine Frank I think once happy
birthday
something something cheeky Bishop takes
wow gastly's really good by the way he
grabbed the pawn oh I know no the man's
been grinding we did a chess lesson for
three hours Monday he went home and
played more chess like until 2AM he
really loves chess
did you also go to the hike in the vegan
restaurant with him or that was another
day that was another day yes but he did
teach me music production so we're
trading each other's crafts
yeah you got like a little dj career
going yeah I I know oh that's not a
that's not is it big is it a big career
it will be big and you know who won't be
invited to the shows you
it wasn't gonna come even if I was
invited so that makes my life easy
I'm just kidding if I was invited no no
it's fine I mean you you literally came
out on my boxing fight not to support me
but to support my opponent so I don't
expect you to support me who invited me
first if you invited me first maybe I
would wait well I did ask you one day
when we were doing a chess stream if
you're coming and you're like
oh yeah she already booked my ticket she
booked my what can I do I see it's easy
to buy your friendship huh
well if I
um by the way can I just back up real
quick while while we're having this
debate um take take
not a great move not not a terrible move
but the idea was to go here
unfortunately
The Rook there was also hanging so an
apocalyptic demolition of the board
and now daily dose is winning not just
because he has a past Pawn which is very
good for the end game but because he's
threatening various checkmates so if he
plays Rook here he could actually go for
a Checkmate as well and push this Pawn
that's true he does love his hikes he's
a nature man this would be crazy if he
sees that I I haven't seen much of his
chest so I don't know how much of a wild
card he is
solid play this is great as well
protecting the passer Rook always goes
behind
dad
this is a very high level game of chess
uh
like I'm like I'm I'm a guest Lee good
one good one yeah yeah that plan wow
daily dose is committing to this Pawn he
doesn't even care about setting up a
cheap mate on G7
no there's no no reason not to it's
gonna take the Knight a big effort to
get back and it's really difficult to
defend because white can go here
take take and just bull those in yeah
this is a very difficult position he
micro Queen H4 but there's nothing there
nothing there at all the king just
slides back yeah I think both of these
opponents are very underrated chat
they're definitely not uh 700. this is a
great game no blunders so far or maybe
the 700 meta has just you know like 710
years ago would eat the pieces
that is true they're evolving yeah now
people know ELO hell exists at 500 too
it's not it's not not all that's a good
move to try to get the queen in the game
nice assign a Desperado attack almost
he plays E5 and I mean those could just
ignore it which is the best move I don't
know if he I don't know just stacked the
pawn
yeah just sack and just just go for the
D5 Pawn they'll be hanging Pawns in the
center yeah I mean Black's Pieces Just
gases nine is on the side of the board
there is pieces aren't as active and
White's attack is just gonna be faster
also they've played 25 moves in like two
minutes so it's a very different pace
the other opponents were playing very
very slowly
this game is fast paced and they're
averaging 74 accuracy which is really
really really good
and that matters right because I think
the average accuracy of your games
contributes to what color you play in
the tie break unless they change that
rule he played the best move
wow daily dose is very impressive
and there's all sorts of traps when you
have a pawn this deep into a position
you can anchor a piece like this to try
to push it further you can also push it
he could push the pawn if takes Queen B8
check is a fork
oh God I'm worried this is my student at
the end of the day he we really worked
hard and trained for this event I I
don't want this game to end just yet
that's not the best move but he I get
what he's doing right and he wants to
remove the queen and then push his best
move was to keep the queen on the board
in the pawn queen was very dangerous yes
the quality of White's Queen was higher
than the quality of Black's Queen but
it's very difficult to play this move
because you're like I want my queen you
know I want to go here
so I don't know I don't know if he's
gonna take if he doesn't think he's
losing
everything else is a lot of pressure
yeah very tough moment here should we
tune in yeah I would love that all right
let's go to Gastly
shout out to Jarvis by the way just saw
him in the twitch chat great match as
much as he wanted to claim it was not
it was a great match we will be here to
coach
um yeah let's take a look at Gastly
assume he he's not oh he might be
trading oh
put the queen down if you're not ready
to make a move
[Music]
uh I literally just keep that there uh
this is gonna make it a little bit more
difficult for me in the long run okay
all right the thing about Gastly why I
think he's a very strong competitor he
really considers Zola's options he
doesn't Rush too much and where does he
go she goes
right there right there
that could be an issue
um
maybe he'll find Queen H4
thanks
the queen hover is stressing me out
because I feel like at any point he
might just accidentally Mouse slip yes
he might forget where it came from down
he's gonna start pushing that pawn a
little bit more a little bit harder I
think it would be best I don't want to
trade my queen I can still come back
uh
the bishop doesn't really have any crazy
protection here plus I can get into yeah
I'm not gonna trade oh wow took a risky
decision here yeah let's go back to the
analysis board this is a very human
decision by the way and in that time
daily dose actually found that he could
take the pawn and defend the bishop this
is ridiculously high level chess
spotting this
and defending himself and now he's
noticed that Gastly is going for this
but there is nothing there if white
plays C7 he wins and queen
like because the Knight can't help
yeah I mean he could try some tricks
Knight G3 Knight F1 but if white sees
how to win with this pass on which daily
dose has definitely been on top of it
it's not gonna do anything oh my God he
just played Queen D7 so fast and now
he's secured control over them and it
goes to the machine
you know I had a feeling
I was a little nervous about this
matchup for Gastly but wow daily dose is
not missing
does he have an anonymous account
because on his account it said he hasn't
played since 2022. this guy hasn't
played since 2022
oh my God on the right side right side
Sea Dog might not be the strongest
player okay yes he's trying to go for
this but unfortunately there's no checks
after King G1
and you know what the worst part is
there's no way for white to mess this up
I know you could Jinx like that I know
if like but there's literally not the
Knight can't get close
the queen doesn't even have a check
anymore
like White's just going here here he's
just completely winning he did all this
starting with the bird it's even more
painful I know
I know
yeah
yeah this is uh this is wild stuff no no
reaction no emotions like a like a real
killer game's over nothing
yeah I'm trying to find a way that white
could possibly screw this up and it it
literally does not exist because the
Rook has to move
C7 is next
oh I think he knows it's over did we
hear daily doses commentary
yeah we'll see it's practically it's
literally game over
what's he talking about daily dose
okay
why would you do that do that okay
I guess it stops
but doesn't happen Gastly had no choice
an advantage there when I just do
I like that even considers
a free rook it's like huh there must be
something
I don't see daily dose making any
blenders he checks over every move he's
even completely winning moves so we're
getting better it's just
it's just
it's so clean this this was the most
clean game of all time wow
um
all right
yeah white could even set up a little
mate Bishop C3 Queen coming to the
background I don't really have to go
anywhere I had the luxury now so I could
actually give my
my king additional protection if I
really want to and I can I can shove the
bishop like over by like F2 at some
point
it's the Norway air it's like I could
just start hunting down pieces but I
feel like that's not really
useful to me
do I because how can they attack me
[Music]
I think I just start hunting down pieces
at this point
yeah let's do this
the fact that he's just so completely
winning and still carefully thinking
about this I am worried for anyone who's
gonna play daily dose yeah this is not
exact not exactly the best move but it's
you know I mean you can't really mess
this up as white just because there's no
mate threat
um no yeah you literally can I mean okay
you could like hang your Bishop but he
hasn't done anything that crazy and
Bishop here is just checked these
oh my goodness well okay this was a
crazy game but look do not underestimate
Gastly we've done a lot of training
daily dose is very strong but I still
think the next one it's not going to be
so so
early determined listen
it's that Norwegian air I'm telling you
like yeah Madness on speed dial
well no that's not allowed but uh well
maybe does that know what you do
that's you just admitted to cheating I
didn't say for chess moves I may be
emotional support you know you right you
right ooh insinuated they were giving me
chess moves so it's just about the
energy that they bring you know
sometimes I bring Frank on speed dial
that's that's true sometimes you bring
the grand Masters in something yeah yeah
always have the chess players
that must be what daily dose is doing
I'm so mad about that uh this is not
good because white can go here and win
the queen
um if daily those takes
he could get himself in trouble if he
takes okay there could be
he's guaranteed to win the rook and he
always on the board because if this it's
this and if this it's this and if this
he's gonna get mated check Queen B2
oh my goodness all the legends
I don't want to be a biased commentator
I really I I'm rooted for both sides but
it hurts to watch it hurts to watch my
student get slaughtered like that and I
knew he added him I knew he would come
back never doubted once now I'm just
gonna pump the brakes here white is
still the one playing for the win
because he has an outside pass Pawn
black has to make a draw black has to
repeat moves black has to give
professional check I don't even know if
he knows about Perpetual check we didn't
really go over that but I'm sure you'll
figure that out chess beginners learn
things as they go they're like children
they fall off the bike and then they
learn how to not fall off the bike
anymore so he might very well like
blunder a check that Forks the queen and
then it like he had to bring his Queen
back right now he's got to give these
checks okay Moment of Truth we we did
not go over this but she'll see if I
really like a tumble as Levy says
oh oh oh he could Queen F2 is will he
mate himself
Queen F2 literally would have lost the
game now I think it's just the draw King
here check
uh I I just the thing is if you don't
know Perpetual exists why would you do
it you might just be going for something
completely different and he is and hey
he's cool this could have been so close
oh does he know he's playing for a draw
like because you gotta you gotta know
what you're playing for you gotta play
for a draw that's the thing about end
games
you're not playing for a win here with
black
don't trade the queens please
yeah we we didn't quite get to the end
games
um because one of my Grandmaster friends
I was asking them for advice on these
coaching they're like nah don't worry
about end games like No One's Gonna Be
playing those out they're just all the
games are gonna just deciphered early on
Grand Masters are bad coaches
because it's not because they lied
Grandmasters don't understand how real
human beings play chess Grandmasters are
in their own little world
and they're just like you don't need to
learn openings I mean end games or
whatever I don't do these GMS that
sounds like someone's a little jaded
that they never reached GM title yeah
don't even do you even have a title okay
I do not but I don't need one unlike
Frank we have our own Pros okay all
right I am I am I envious of that yeah
of course all right I'm gonna cry after
the stream are you happy
I love that I I you know Levy's tilted
when little Gremlin voices come out like
that was a little Trump voice I wonder
what's next earlier you had like a
little Harry Potter moment you have a
lot of these voices
yeah I probably need therapy by the way
oh Queen D4 oh oh that's defended don't
take it oh this is so sad oh wait
where's he oh where's he going
I was hoping maybe we could walk him
into a fork but it doesn't matter
because A7 Queen D4 Queen blocks and
Gigi doesn't even work
I think this game is not finished with
the plot twists like I I don't
I don't know they're they're very solid
I I would be there's no way there's
another blender
yeah it's very tough yeah he PL now just
don't go Queen E4 that was his honestly
best option to stop okay it got a
question mark So I was wrong but
I don't think there's that many options
Queen E4 tries to promote and
confidently hangs this he has to check
that's not a bad move but it doesn't
help the pawn
okay but
that's it that's the right there Queen
trade by daily dose yep he walked right
into it
but who knows okay
just getting distracted oh my God he's
going on oh oh the pawn and also Pawn
takes oh
thanks Pawn is winning for black
dude you are literally jinxing
everything I don't know how you're
predicting this
I'm not jinxing you said it was over I
said I don't think so this is insane
oh my goodness Pawn takes Pawn deflects
the king and then white black is winning
in the queen and Poland game now okay
but we still didn't study end games so I
I still don't know if we will know how
to take the win home but boy am I happy
we got a second chance the only way he
wins is to bring his king or play I I
don't even think that 504 is winning I
think he has to bring his King to H4 oh
God I the likelihood of stumbling into
this plane without any end games is so
difficult
uh can we tune into ghastly see what
he's thinking yeah yeah critical
position oh my God that was unbelievable
let's take a look at Gastly stream if we
can
he's considering all his options
I blame the grand Masters for this chat
oh all of them they all saw a crazy
comeback right now this has been gnarly
God dang it
but does he know
black has to bring his King
that's the only way
let's go to the analysis board real
quick I just want to show this because
this actually is very instructive
um
he has built this Pawn Fortress so now
daily dose has to stay here he has to
stay right in this rectangle or this
Pawn is going to get in he can't go
there obviously he'll hang his King uh
now black wins by just walking up to the
pond but he has to do it in the wrong
way down
he could get frustrated get close and
then he can't win the pawn because the
king comes back this is look at this
he's gonna go forward
and now he can't make progress he has to
go the other way he can't get frustrated
and push he has to go around
oh my God he found it well it's good
when you're getting forced into
fundingly your only option yes literally
had almost no other move
yes Unstoppable but see this is why we
don't teach him end games they just
learn him oh all right
second tries to turn oh my God don't
repeat the moves wait has that position
already happened I don't know is this
the third I really hope not okay oh God
no no no no it's a drop by repetition I
take no accountability for this oh they
repeated three times and it's a draw
this is all my fault I should have
thought of any games I
thought oh
let's get a live reaction I don't know
from either of them daily dose what does
he think he was losing
I am fired
all right next game you guys need more
commentators I won't be a coach anymore
next game starts in two to three minutes
so okay that was a great reaction from
him he just left
he's gotten out of that situation oh
yeah
coach in there bro he's got the
Norwegians I'm telling you
there was someone in that room it's
Magnus on speed dial
yeah no one curious who's in there you
uh I think you know what's up
wow I think you know what's up I I got a
little distracted with the chat but I I
all right I'm just saying I heard a
little birdie in Daily dose's room
I think he was talking to himself it is
Alan Walker it could be
uh uh one game is in the books
half for gasly
have for daily dose of Internet a
Titanic struggle
from start to finish this okay I know I
was gonna make I was gonna get in
trouble for this joke
no please go ahead what was what was the
joke I say this just proves my thesis
all white guys are the same we gotta
drop we're gonna get another one Jesus
Christ oh my God
what I'm just okay all right let me know
and I don't condone this like so y'all
gonna take some legal action man I'm I'm
not a part of this I don't even just
kidding the ties will surely change
don't worry oh oh my God okay it's half
half after all right okay I'm a little
biased I can roast them they just they
look like all my ex-boyfriends so I will
admit that's why I'm a little salty okay
anything you want to share with the
class or brunette and they looked like
that and they had the same haircut it's
just the same formula and you just can't
trust those people it's a it's a recipe
for disaster
I don't even know what I'm this what
I
okay so I suddenly forgive you for all
the times you've roasted me about the
Grand Master title I I I I can we get a
demographic on the screen why are we
still full screen
I just like putting Olivia in
uncomfortable situations oh my goodness
yeah there's a legendary one where you
called Lucy uh my girlfriend and then
never forgot it happened when are we
gonna have a child
um that was that was a good one you know
the one I'm talking about the very first
sub battle
uh yes the answer is yes
totally castley's on the screen
we got Castle here
he's he's doing good
um
wow that was that was an intense round
that was an intense round of Chess I uh
I don't know how he's so calm I get
really nervous when I play in these
events all right uh Matt just starting
in a few seconds now they've got game
number two coming out pieces this time
oh yeah he is with the white pieces did
you review his openings with white
well you know I asked if you wanted to
play the London he said he's got it
figured out so never taught him to
London so you know we just focused on
other things
I noticed that he plays E4
um
watch
he's going to uh
Dad yeah that's not gonna work yeah the
ponziani doesn't quite work against
Knight F6
is he gonna play here to try to play the
ponziani that's gonna be very funny or
is he just gonna play like yeah we
didn't discuss the backup plan but
solid opening so far so we'll see
Knight C3 yeah well done
very nice let's develop the Bishops
I have to say though daily dose is just
a little bit of a silent killer like
there was you know that game turned into
a draw but the way he found that winning
Pawn push I am I'm a little scared
no that end game was unbelievable and
and and the fighting Spirit between the
two of them like to go to Queen and
three versus queen and two was uh was
absurd uh this is gonna be a long boring
game because they've got a lot of Pawns
it's gonna be a lot of maneuvering
you're you're really good at hyping up
chess commentary Levy yeah just like you
do this for a living or something you're
almost too good at it oh no no I should
be paying you for this I definitely
don't uh don't cast live games but I I
Recaps
it's like
Mike Breen is a sports you know uh
broadcaster for the NBA he does the live
coverage but he doesn't do the recap so
it's very different
um all right we got a poll and chat we
have gassy daily dose or Draw I predict
another draw
oh you think we're getting a playoff
maybe no chance
no chance why is everyone saying Andrea
for the mod what does that mean what
happened I I don't know I I think I
think gasly's gonna I think Gastly might
pull it off
yeah no this is it's much easier to play
an aggressive opening rather than what
he had that fianchetto set up
he's going to go for the bishop he's
going to play F4 I also just
some insights
insights I
was like 1200 with the white pieces
because he was confident he was out the
gate
but
black I think he might be a little shaky
look at this already spending a minute
after the first five moves he can't play
the bird with black
that's true he's not the same without
the bird
oh look at that clean got the bishop
that was a nice capture creating
weaknesses in the opponent's light
squares we actually talked about this if
Gastly plays F4 I think he wins bog gems
just calling it right now if he plays
Pawn to F4 mobilizing
that would be a beautiful
much more likely that he plays like D4
develops a bishop but if he goes here
is my student
energy
for these um principles so I'm I'm not
surprised but I I'm not gonna celebrate
too early
yeah yeah for a very clean opening let's
just say I actually taught him this
actually I forgot to say but I this is
theory that we talked about to play F4
in this exact position yep yep
yeah we didn't spend time on end games
but we did this and it worked yeah
simply the best coach of bog Champs so
you know if any pogsham's competitors
want some coaching I I make prodigies
obviously yeah yeah no for sure
um
Bishop to E3 now he's got a good
structure
of course you don't just win a game from
one move but just the the understanding
there look at those pawns those double
isolated Pawns
is celebrating in another world no okay
yeah I thought very confidently
it practically didn't happen we'll just
solid opening ladies and gentlemen
nothing nothing missed here so the
reason people are 750 or 704 is because
some of us play like we're 654 and 754
Tina's in the chat she taught sorry I
got so excited it's like you and your
mom watch the stream like hi Mom it's me
I'm on the big screen at timeout pawns
and she tell me about isolated pawns and
double pawns and I said the words and
she's the best chess teacher ever and I
hope I make her proud today everything
to say to Dina Gotham
uh happy to have you in the chat uh and
thank you for teaching and Andrea about
what did she teach you
yeah yeah yep yep Pawn structures all
right um go on no I was just saying that
you know people are 700 because it's a
range so ghastly played a really good
move like a 1000 and played really bad
move like a 400 right it's just a range
there you go it's just like a range of
you know the person's skill level so he
blundered Queen D4 but neither of them
saw it it was a tough move very
close close combat type of move and uh I
have no idea what's gonna happen because
The Bishop's staring at this Rook is
staring at that Knight is staring at
this this Knight could go here and here
I wonder what Hikaru would play in this
position with white well he was probably
just celebrating his wedding he wouldn't
be playing
yeah but like if he was what would he
play it was it's a historic day Carlo
got married you know he's might just
retired but actually
did I did I tell you how I'm spreading
the Hikaru tattoo across the chess
community
you know it's a thing now that a lot of
chess players are getting and you could
sign up for it if you'd like
okay about the latest Trend in the chess
Community it's really popular Eric
Hansen's doing it Nemo's doing it it's
eventually your turn Levy okay wow all
right uh what are they doing exactly
they're all getting a temporary Hikaru
tattoo
and maybe you don't we could even do a
little side gamble today Levy like you
know if my student wins or something you
get a tattoo and if my student loses I
get a tattoo I think it's time to bring
back the ikaru tattoo I think you should
just get a tattoo I I will not be
getting a tattoo but it's only fun if
you're you know competing for it amongst
two
listen there's a lot of people in the
chest uh directory that you that you
could you know wager a tattoo against
like daily dose who we're about to
listen into I think all right your mouth
What if I
see we're supposed to hear him he's
there a quiet leash
what if I start putting pressure up here
no I don't want to do that
I put it I put up there
that's a good move that's a good move
that's a great move right I think that's
a good move
I think that's good
because the Knight will protect it
good
feeling safe we can lock in the bishop
I feel really bad for him because Chad
is yelling that it's not a good move
because the computer is saying that it's
not but it's a it's a very reasonable
move uh it's calling it a miss
because Knight takes G4 was the winning
idea deflecting the queen from the
defense of the pawn which would attack
the rook and remove the defense of that
pawn and also lead to Knight E3 which
could potentially be another Fork so the
computer wanted you to see all of that
uh daily those did not because he's a
real person and not an AI you know what
but that's
now that's a grand master move
I don't know much about gunmasters but I
know that they like to bring their
Knights back so he must have been taking
notes yeah the problem is that's winning
again he doesn't see it though oh no
ah no no not the Rook again please don't
take with the queen just think with the
pun no one needs to see this is that
like this everything was so solid oh he
drew the car he just drove the car
straight off the cliff and jumped out
oh my goodness but only if daily dose
finds Queen takes
that's true there's um
only 30 chance there's three ways to
take here
30 33 yeah but also we don't know yeah
we don't know maybe he's not gonna do it
because he didn't do it earlier I don't
know
can we can we listen I feel like the
move's about to happen he took the pawn
and we're saved oh wow okay now the
night oh I'm starting to think this is
very interesting because they play very
solid chess when it comes to fighting
these moves but the tactics you need to
bring more puzzle rush into the training
or both sides
oh my goodness yeah I uh
I told all of my secret students that
they had to go grind puzzles and they
need to solve a hundred percent of them
successfully I
think I told them to do 15 minutes of
puzzles every day I don't know if it
happened but
well technically you could do 15 minutes
of puzzles but get them all wrong right
well you know it's the effort that
counts yeah like I did 15 minutes of
puzzles
and I got like that's why this is
everybody's always like oh I do these
puzzles but I never saw them in the game
ah 19 is winning again
white needed to put his Knight here fast
because otherwise black is just going to
go like this
white is just gonna be so ahead so
behind in development but it's not that
simple to see why this is winning
especially at this level
no 100 right like white does not realize
how important this is right now because
I think also as your 700 you're not
thinking oh he's gonna do this whereas
if you're as you're going up the rating
ladder you're like this is a huge
weakness and I could put my knight there
so that blocks everything blah blah
I don't know this this game their
accuracy has both gone down about 20 so
maybe fatigue is setting in
you know we started very strong and it
just keeps dwindling and dwindling
oh but I don't know if daily dose
doesn't find yeah he's just pushing his
pawns he's just not
oh oh God it's still there but now
he might be forced to take because
ghastly is setting up Bishop takes Pawn
that is also if he sees the thread on E6
but
it's not too sneaky
no it's a very very clear indication of
hostility Knight takes G4 now is a
defensive move but it's actually still
winning for black
and unfortunately White's accuracy has
now dipped to 47 last game it was like
73 I mean just the very chaotic second
game
yeah this it doesn't seem like well okay
oh wow okay he's choosing to defend he
doesn't want to take the bishop he just
doesn't want it he doesn't need it to
win if Gastly gets his Knight to C4 he
will survived this I think he's also
gonna win like I just he'll never be
attacked anymore but I can't predict the
results in this game the last six moves
no the last five moves by both players
10 moves straight have been bad
they have just totally lost the threat
of the game they're not realizing that
this is winning and that this is winning
and white is just allowing I don't know
what he's going to do he might go here
and re- oh goodness this is terrifying
I mean at this point white is just
forced yeah to find the best moves they
like you we had this lesson there we go
we talked about you don't know what to
do and you haven't moved into pieces
look at the pieces that you haven't
moved and he found it okay Knight C4
Knight C4 let's go oh there it is that's
like putting the last puzzle piece down
on the puzzle
and that's it like there's no more
yep
there's a lot of ways for black to lose
for example Bishop D6 defending the pawn
and hanging Bishop E6 because the Rook
no longer defends Bishop D6 loses and
it's a very natural looking move by the
way because it defends the pawn queen C7
loses
everything is losing unless you take the
bishop
but I think yes similar to how Gastly
was forced to develop his Knight might
just happen the same for this bishop
trade because otherwise like you said
all his pieces are tied up
yeah they're all tied up I mean he he
hasn't taken the bishop for like six
moves so is he gonna take it now is he
gonna realize he has to or is it just
program that he's not going to take it
I'm telling you I'm predicting this or
this
you know I wouldn't be opposed to seeing
another boat as Gambit like it's just
part of the tournament now which is like
a nice and Casual Queen D6 the problem
with Queen D6 is that it hangs a queen
and then it hangs a rook too so it's a
yeah Bishop Bishop D6 because the E6 you
take forking the queen
yeah then you could lose your queen
anyway okay
Knight takes Pawn all right he's not
walking into it now he's gonna be up a
clean Pawn just take the right Pawn
wow
play and hesitate and he has to go back
if he doesn't go back daily dose will
get this and that's kind of scary
obviously the queen is hanging so you
gotta move the queen
well you know not obvious to everyone
that's something could happen that's
true he might not see it
uh
oh man
it's crazy how Gastly came back in this
game
I was so sure it was daily dose's game
yeah and daily dose is also down to
three minutes
that's not enough time
okay you gotta go back
but I think frustrated look he might I
think he might go forward because that's
again more natural
but if he goes back he's a beast
let's go check uh on gasly oh he went
back
let's still check in with him
Outpost nights let's go
some deep thoughts here
well he's turned off the music oh I know
he did never mind I'm gonna say he's
damn he's talking way too much he's
gonna distract himself
I think actually one reason he kind of
messed up in the first one he was
talking about is his first time kind of
streaming games on Twitch and he was
talking a lot during his first game and
he seemed a little distracted
but maybe you know AI generated video on
Loop who knows maybe both these
opponents
yeah both these opponents are just AIS
that'd be daily dose you never know the
man's machine uh E5 hits the Knight
great move every move that that ghastly
has played since Knight to D2 has built
actually frankly since Queen D1 like he
made a blunder this move followed that
and then that move and then this move
and then this move then he took the pawn
then he came back then he pushed every
move has followed the previous move now
we have this
and he's just much better he's just a
much better position but the problem to
win this is you have to be slow
yeah I think we briefly talked about
this plan actually creating a battery
with the Rooks but for like 10 seconds
at the end of our lesson
um but I have to say his intuition has
been very strong
yeah if he gets something to F7 whether
it's by doubling his Rogues or playing
Queen G6 he's just gonna win like right
now uh by the way he has a fork
that's
you could see it you could see it
because you it's it's nice but as we've
seen puzzles haven't been oh a daily
dose season ah
missed it they don't see each other
because he wouldn't be a good poker
player but let's see but but Rook F2
white didn't see Knight B6 the fork and
that's that's very simple to do because
you know he's not looking for the
tactics
that shall be our next Focus
the daily dose is given a second chance
yep that would have been a big big loss
for black but black is still doing okay
good job
I I think Rook C8 might happen and then
there's another Fork
oh no
I I just I if he didn't see it the first
time I don't I don't know if he's gonna
see it the second but
wait at this point he finished his plan
so maybe he's looking I hope he doesn't
play this thinking it's mate or like of
course he could trade but Knight B6 is
just game over you know this is a
critical moment come on let's go let's
take the home win and you can see this
stuff because it's so close your eyes
should be drawn to this area and you go
oh that's kind of nice
I don't think he does he see it
see
Frank was here the fork would have been
done cheeky Fork oh I don't know Frank
all right let's I think we're gonna tune
in and look
I want my knight to be a bit more useful
so I'm going to jump my knight right
here
attack The Rook I could take that pawn
but I really don't
the the pressure's over here right now
uh I take Pawn I like Pawn take I like
Ponte and then go back
oh God the night's gonna go inside I
guess it can always go back but opening
some opportunities massive developments
let's go back to the big board uh so
Gastly took a free Pawn don't blame him
he just missed Knight B6 daily dose is
trying to trade all the pieces the
problem with doing that is he's just
down material
he's just down material he's down two
pawns I believe
and he he can't move anything she can't
move any pawns this Knight is a God I
just my my concern here is based on our
last end game with that um Perpetual I
don't know if it matters if we're up
pawns it's it
if you haven't gone over the end game
it's not clear to win these with extra
material no no definitely not
definitely not
okay H4 would be beautiful that would be
a nice
yeah H4 would be nice do you know what
the worst part is white is up two pawns
but can't move them they're here and if
you play here you could lose the oh my
god do they know about on passant
I know we didn't do that one either I
don't know I don't know he probably does
right because he's played a lot he
definitely oh he's very new to the game
he's only been studying for like
four months okay so not
not sure okay please don't play a4ba I
will lose it
I will lose it
eventually process illumination is gonna
try them all and then you'll make it to
the other side of the board and then H4
and it's gonna be okay Ah that's we go
back hopefully yeah the thing is that
once you remove okay I predict Queen
here Queen C6 is the best move forcing
the Knight back ah check okay all right
I don't know if he sees it though
because the tunnel vision I called it I
called it Queen E6 now to defend the
night
oh
does he does he oh
my camera
oh
all right now it's just me hello Chad
hello Chad it's just me and and the
guide that's a brilliant move and a
mistake and
uh well
Queen takes Queen and three pawns up and
he's Off to the Races
what's up Chad
hello I think Ludwig's doing a watch
party hello chess.com stream on multiple
platforms alright I will be your uh I
will be the captain of your flight today
to uh
Norway I think that's where daily dose
is Queen C4
Mutual pin here on the queen
could take and the best move for white
at that point would be to take with the
pawn
okay uh hello uh that was a countdown oh
and all of this happened
they thought they fired me I'm back all
of that happened by the way and the
night is now hanging the phone is a
passer is this gonna be a winning end
game do you think gassy is going to
bring home the win
uh it's dead again oh I've never had
this issue before I'm sorry
okay I'll be back just the Black Box you
gotta bring your king that's the only
way to win the end game he has to bring
his King if you really oh my goodness
this man is an absolute gangster King F3
King E4 look at him go it's Magnus
Carlson in Disguise C5 C6 take oh my
goodness Gastly is bringing us home his
accuracy has gone up 20 since the lowest
point I've also lost Andrea on Discord
by the way they do
she is not connected there anymore uh
oh my goodness it's just me the chat and
and and and and and the watch party yes
producer I am running solo yes and the
producers producers are always here King
to D5
and it's just gonna be a walk for the
pawns the only thing Gastly has to do is
not freak out over here C6 on the board
confidence pawn to C6 Pawn to C7 don't
freak out don't allow the pawn to get
through
okay I'm very scared two and a half
minutes ghastly a lot of people get
scared here they're gonna do something
no no no no why are you touching that
pawn this Pawn is three squares away
from quitting oh my goodness beginners
are gonna give me a heart attack this is
the pawn that's gonna become a queen not
this one okay
okay now you gotta go back right
now you gotta push please push the more
advanced Pawn I'm not cheering for
anybody I'm simply cheering for good
chess
King F4 just push the thank you then the
good news is you can push both
the bishop cannot stop both pawns that
close E6
E6 on the board and then sneak one
through yeah King's Not Really Gonna
help
but it could Pawn okay just oh God oh
God it's actually very scary because
after Pawn takes there's King takes oh
no
oh but the pawn takes and not the king
the king had to take and now this is a
winning race for why push the E Pawn
does Gastly see it
does he see that he can push the e-pawn
oh my God is he trying to defend this
Pawn is he gonna go after that pawn
he sees it he sees it
now the only thing preventing a victory
is a stalemate and there is a way to
there is a way to stalemate you can
accidentally take this pawn and it will
be a draw somehow if the king is stuck
don't resign you never resign here you
resign here you are Ace a lunatic
you never resign
you finish the game
somehow
somehow he's got to make a move King H2
now all you do here with white is you
sack the queen for the pawn and you make
a new one easiest way to win or Force
the king in front of the pawn yep and
just go just go you don't need to you
don't gotta get close now this cheeky
fancy stuff just just go
great fantastic
oh amazing amazing Eddie resigns daily
dose does not see that I would not
resign I disagree with the decision
but we're gonna check it on Gastly as he
wins the match in an epic fashion
oh the internet we got the dub
oh let's go
LLY
GG
we see the reaction there
that was a fantastic match honestly
pogsham's 5 is off to an incredible
start minus the Andrea disconnect but so
far we've had very very back and forth
matches
uh and two of them decided in the second
game by a score of one and a half to
half uh Gastly takes the win over daily
dose of internet in group b
and I I mean I'm assuming we're going to
show the standings but if not then
obviously you know Gastly is up top with
three points
um and uh we will take a a short breakup
we're gonna try to get an interview with
the players but before we do uh my
friends we've got a special shout out
from chess.com uh if you've been wanting
to try out chess.com premium features
before committing to a membership right
now is the best time cash in on the
chess.com summer offer to unlock 30 days
premium for absolutely free you can
enjoy a full month of unlimited puzzles
lessons game reviews and more and the
offer ends tomorrow July 27th I don't
know if that's at midnight or when so
don't miss your chance you can use
exclamation point claim in the chat to
unlock 30 days of Premium right now
this has been an awesome day so far very
tense matches back and forth we're gonna
link up with the players see if one or
both are going to join us for an
interview I didn't know they were gonna
have my full room back here I would have
cleaned up that side
we'll be right back short break and an
interview with the players coming up
I had no other move except to lose
that's a good move
that's a great move right I think that's
a good move
he did not see my mistake
he did not see that mistake running
all right gg gg daily dose of Internet
we got the dub
let's go
[Music]
I understand 18 seconds for a black so
not too much time there either Rook C7
a7's falling uh it is E4 he pushes the
pawn this is getting a little messy
takes a knight F1
move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played
takes it
takes it right yeah
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that was there and instead he
played here
oh my God A7 wins for white oh my gosh
[Music]
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
click the Subscribe button see if it
says subscribe free and purple and if it
does you're golden Ponyboy anyway let's
check on who's priming right now
oh [__] it's my friend
[Music]
um
Willis hey Willis can't wait to grab
lunch later catch you on the flippity
flip
anyway back to the chess content you
guys have a good one
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone to our continued
coverage of fog Champs five two
mattresses in the books and now it's
time to move on to the second half of
the day uh that was a lot of fun Andrea
not you crashing but uh oh thanks
I so my camera died but I heard my
student brought home the dub I'm not
gonna take the credit even though you
know I gotta say it's no coincidence
it's because he had an amazing coach
that's true I mean the games were like
Blood Sweat and Tears he was on the
verge of death a couple of times you
know but the most important thing is
that he got it done in the end uh it was
exhilarating it was a crazy end game he
played really really well actually so
both games went into the end game uh but
that's all in the books so we have a
leader in group a and Group B but now
it's time for the next two matchups and
let's preview them by putting them up on
the screen we've got Ginny who makes a
lot of IRL content specifically about
travel as far as I know traveling to
different cities yep walking around
exploring
um and she is taking on
like a top five OG Legend of twitch I
mean seriously Tyler won in pogchamps is
Sensational stuff I knew who Tyler won
was before I knew what live streaming
was and
it's kind of surreal to see him playing
chess
we'll see what type of chest that is
that is actually our next matchup and
then we've got Sea Dog and that's the
that's the finish of group a taking on
saikuno uh saikuno's got his work cut
out for him in that match Andrea what
are your expectations yeah first off I'm
so excited to have Tyler one in this POG
Champs we had era blast POG Champs it
must be really hard for Tyler to always
live up to the expectations of his
sibling you know I can really understand
but don't worry Tyler you're gonna do
great hopefully one day we could even
have a Tyler vs xqc matchup I know this
is one that the chats really want to see
Jenny I'm very biased I love her we've
done IRL with but I don't know much
about her chess
um but I think they're about the same
level
yeah I also don't know much about her
chest let's pull up her player card
um I I have to tell you when I read this
I I it's like I'm so used to seeing TSM
spelled out so she she signed to team
solo mid I didn't realize we were going
by like legal names she's got nearly 100
uh not 100 I'm gonna say a million
nearly a million followers uh on Twitch
just like me I think I have 998 000 so
I'm I'm close too uh and uh she's
trilingual she speaks English Korean and
Chinese
I'm only bilingual uh Andrea do you
speak how good is your Romanian uh my
Romanian is pretty fluid
but it unfortunately doesn't help me
playing chess though
and we we see Ginny right there uh I was
worried she didn't have a crop correctly
like she she didn't have the clock
visible but it's there it's just at the
bottom she yeah Jenny I have to say
she's a real one for still pulling
through I know her like frame setup died
a little bit ago and her laptop died she
has almost as good of a setup as I do
right now so shout out to Jenny for
making this happen from I think she's in
Denmark
wow everyone's everywhere huh yes
everyone's traveling stepped us except
except and except Tyler I think I think
Tyler he uh he hangs out he hangs out at
the house
uh I know that's that's a big thing he's
uh always lifting weights you can't
travel when you have to spend so much
time in the gym because he has gigantic
muscles like it really does they are
enormous um he's the League of Legends
streamer of the year the last two years
I'm the chess streamer of the Year by
the way uh runner-up is my co-host uh
Tyler uh he's the host he hosts the
tyler1 championship series
and he's a former running back at
Central they had no third bullet they
had to talk about his football career
yeah no I have to say the football the
trilingual my great facts they dug I
mean my goodness is that gonna help him
today how fast he can run on the
chessboard I don't know one of these
must one of these must shout out to
Tyler Tyler I I see he's watching the uh
the broadcast uh huge fan I like I said
I knew like two or three streamers
existed before I knew what live
streaming was and their names are
lexweld house disguisedos and Tyler like
I knew Tyler won so does that mean
you're you're rooting for Tyler today
I'm I'm just rooting for chess I'm
rooting for chess and and our previous
two matchups
yes uh my the last two matchups have
been very close very tense Jarvis really
stepped up we didn't know how good he
was going to be this might be these
might be slightly more on the beginner
side but we don't know I mean Tyler's
been on the grind and he's also very
intimidating so we're about to see we're
about to see how much chess they've
played
yeah for this one I would love to just
tune in and hear what they're thinking I
don't think I've ever seen Ginny or
Tyler play chess before so this is this
is an historic historic day
Genie with the 182
I think the I think cyclun was close
with 199 he's coming up next Tyler is
259 which is also like his warm-up bench
press yeah no 199 he's just trying to
make it in the under 200 group for the
next sub battles like don't don't think
that this isn't because he's not good
enough to be 200 it's actually because
he likes being right at the edge
no it's totally understandable right
like I you know I I don't go above 2800
Blitz on chess.com because I just want
to be 2800 yeah that's why I haven't hit
2000 in a couple months again
there you go uh D4 is played and uh
Jenny took a minute to make her first
move she played the Queen's Pawn Tyler
played a move so fast that he has more
than 10 minutes
and I think his goal might be to end the
game with 11 minutes on the clock
because he's playing very fast
is a speed machine you know it's not
going to slow down for chess
I saw a message in the chat that said
Ginny has been getting coached by Duda
in Poland is that just an absolute lie
what honestly at this point there it's
either completely true or there's no
shot but I asked if she had any chest
training and um I I don't think she's
had time for it because she has been
traveling the world
um but who knows maybe secretly she's
training with Duda from Poland
but that's such an absurd lie that like
it's believable you know
like that's a crazy thing to like that's
such a specific lie that I mean it
almost makes sense based on this
gameplay the G4 the bishop in front of
e3 I I think she is improvising on her
openings
yeah
yeah I don't oh and Tyler just snapped
snaps that pawn off the board yeah Duda
I don't think
would have prepared her in Bishop to E3
uh could be a new one we'd maybe just
don't know about it yet yep we don't
know it could be the next big opening
Bishop takes is a very nice move
and this could go from bad to worse very
quickly but we'll see we'll see how
tyler1 plays I think this is a Gambit on
Ginny's part and she wanted to open the
file for her Rook because she knows that
Tyler's gonna get intimidated and he's
she's not gonna let him Castle she
actually just has a very aggressive
attacking plan
okay there it is there's the attacking
thing I think he's gonna be attacking
it's a it's a plan
listen
I know a thing if if Tyler shows
restraint here and doesn't just snap the
Knight off and he just backs up and says
the bishop is better than the Knight
that's high level stuff but Bishop takes
is fine it's completely fine move I love
it every time you you describe Tyler's
chest it's always snapping things it's
not just capturing it's like he's
making a bounce light does it okay he
didn't snap the knife you know I've seen
him play it's it's vicious do you think
Tyler is the type to chess rage to like
you know break through a door if he was
to lose a game
hell yeah but so am I like who is it
you've you've told me you've never
thrown a phone or a raged the chess
that's the one thing I can say I've
never done
I've never had chest rage I don't break
things when I lose chess games listen I
once said that to Hikaru and then Hikaru
was like well that's why you're not an
accomplished yeah no that's exactly what
I was gonna say it's probably because
like I don't get that invested and I
lose a lot so who knows
yeah well Bishop here so she's played
completely fine she just doesn't have a
g Pawn that's okay oh part of the Gambit
Jenny's Gambit
Castle
oh okay yep yep manifested that one
she's got the principles I'm a little
worried about us castling straight into
the line of fire
um but that's only if Tyler knows how to
use the line of fire
yeah Tyler's taking his time got the two
minute lead will he Castle as well uh
one good strategy for beginners is to
lay your opponent castle and then Castle
the other way
and then you could launch a giant attack
so some beginners wait to see if their
opponent is gonna Castle but some just
to hear and hear and whatever and then
we'll we'll figure it out
do you think Tyler's gonna Castle in
this game what's your prediction
I think so I think his next move is
going to be this and then just
idea of that move
to lose the pawn but open The Rook can
we get a tyler1 looking
is that the point you know my prediction
is he wanted to go G4 and he didn't
realize it was hanging but it could work
out in his favor
no no no no I think that was I think
he's gonna go Rook G8
well let's
let's let's look in
like it took 30 seconds for that move
like I [__] up just take my piece
already
why you have to be mad
he's thinking about it
he's thinking I yeah he he definitely
thinks he messed up
hey this
is dude now that's moved
what was this stopping me from doing
is he speaking or are those
text-to-speech alerts and I swap for
Bishop and then I can take this
I never heard him so bad take his Queen
it's not bad right so I go here what's
he gonna take this
this no it's a good move let's go yeah
let's go back to the big screen actually
he he's got a really good position
I also uh
uh he played Bishop to H6 which is fine
as long as he finds this move
his accuracy right now is 93 percent
yep and here you could try to create
some weaknesses around the king Take the
bishop just don't hang the bishop on H6
and he has a beautiful plan of attack on
the king yeah as long as he exactly as
long as he sees this he'll be all right
but
oh I don't know I don't know if he's
gonna be all right the thing is when
you're when you're really really a
beginner like 200 you you can't even get
yourself to make trades because you're
like if I take they take me
and I don't want them to take me but
like you can't play chess like that like
and he doesn't okay very nice
nope not scared at all yeah if I was
dude I'd be pissed right now oh yeah
Duda really needs to uh um
so
this is
this is literally running it down mid
basically
that what the gamers do oh that's a
football thing running down mid
right I thought that was a gaming term
no but I don't know I thought that was
more of a football analogy yeah that's
okay
oh I see
I yeah I liked
I liked I liked I liked all of this
see the thing is it's a nice well I
guess he has threats like H3 it's a nice
Rook move but if no one tells you to do
these things you're not going to stumble
upon them on your own
League of Legends Levy no of course not
my quality of life is so high
it's it's already bad enough with chess
I can't play chess and League
see I'm not the only one who doesn't
know
well I knew the term okay clearly
clearly listen I was a diamond OverWatch
player like all right
diamond in OverWatch is like being a
2000 a chess it's right at that level
you just start thinking you're good
enough but you're actually still so dog
[__] like you cannot it's really good
I'm above 2 000 so yeah well you're also
not a player that like you're not like a
gatekeeper you're not like you know
arrogant like 2000s think they're good
but they're so bad oh speaking I mean my
goodness he's got a whole thing going
here
yeah no this is a beautiful position for
Tyler all he has to do is bring out his
pieces
just Queen H4 Rook G8 and he is getting
very passive bringing more pieces back
but that's kind of what happens when
you're panicking you don't know how to
defend so it's very natural
oh my God
beautiful Brook's coming in
what's the plan
I'm gonna go here
I can't take that you hear him he loses
that piece anyway
or she excuse me she she loses this
piece
it's like a little trade so boom
takes it boom
no is there a way to raise his volume
yeah I never thought I would say this
but I I'm struggling to hear Tyler once
you can kill me if I'm if I make this
move right here right yes
oh you see is the Free Pawn
yep it's very strong
can we check it on Ginny oh [__] let's
let's pull up the analysis board real
quick obviously this is his threat and
that's his threat unfortunately for him
that's not Checkmate because
there's a night guarding but
uh so if we can there is a world I can
see that Ginny might want to bring her
Knight back to attack the queen and then
G2 all of a sudden oh no she's bringing
in the other night oh Queen E3 is a nice
move does he see that it's a check that
will be so nice
he had his eye on it yeah if we could
get some Ginny commentary it'd be nice
to hear what both players are thinking
hey let's do that
if we can
the Ginny looks very confident with
herself
oh whoa
no no I didn't bake
of course well if she disconnects this
game doesn't count right maybe that's
the Strat
Knight if Knight it's it then um
then I can eat the night and then
fight with my queen but okay
oh my God okay I can also eat
s oh you saw it
he played the best move and he did Mike
her screen had a little bit of a robotic
melt down there um
that's a great move from Tyler and
Knight takes Knight is just a clean win
of a night
yeah Tyler's putting on the pressure and
Ginny meanwhile is eating the knights so
I don't know if we can defend about this
and this
Tyler has played 12 moves at a 90
accuracy uh Queen g3s yeah he's he's
really
he's really
he's really doing a nice job Knight
takes Knight is is clean Queen takes
Knight is clean oh my goodness he left
no crumbs
yeah Tyler I have to say he's he's
underrated he's not 199. maybe 59.
259 is crazy oh look at look at this
side by side view look at this
production
wow players locked in focused Tyler just
Tyler just cooking it up here I think
we're gonna listen in on time
was he smurfing us
the trade
down
and there's no moves she takes this gone
this gone
maybe doesn't see the knights she she
did play a very natural move uh which is
to attack the queen but unfortunately
the Knight actually sees both of those
squares you know so Knight takes Rook
oh listen a Desperado attempt but there
is a chance now we're really gonna see
how good Tyler is does he see Knight
takes Rook maybe he runs on the screen
and oh wow yeah if I go who's been
training Tyler down
nothing takes I'm not sure
still can't take that Knight
oh yes that's also a good move
down let's say they go down to Suicide
can't go across
I'm worried about my knight right here
though or my king I'm gonna go here
wait it's good wait if he moves
yeah that was a good move he grabs a
second Pawn the Knight stays defended
the Knight can take the Rook
yeah he's just completely winning and at
any moment The Rook can also join the
party so as long as he doesn't panic he
is uh he's going he's going to win I
mean he's
oh Rook F2 is disaster that's just I
mean you could yeah
there's no saving this Levy yeah Queen
takes rook and then like Rook G8 I mean
it but this game's not over that you
could totally still hang something does
he see Queen takes Rook
I have to say I I underestimated him
he's seen everything he keeps taking the
pieces
oh now she has to go Queen takes Knight
which is findable
who do you think
I'm gonna say who do you think can win
between xuc and Tyler one
if that matchup were to happen
well it will because they're in the same
group but uh xqc is like 1100 so he's
definitely a huge favorite you know I'm
gonna put my money on Tyler I think he
could be the next prodigy
I think he's
he's an unsuspected Prodigy look at this
uh a bishop sack you might think he is
giving a free Bishop no he is baiting
the king to get mated on G3 and we will
have a mate within the next 10 moves
yeah I mean to be honest Bishop takes H3
is uh it is it looks like you just lose
a bishop but it's the third move of the
engine okay that's actually crazy I was
just making [__] up that's actually
crazy no it's because the king is out
and queen G3 is mate now the rookie
because he hasn't seen it the entire
game so this is yeah a very testing
moment it's not easy to see and he
hasn't seen it yet I don't know if the
ties will turn just yet
he has to find I mean he lost the bishop
thinking that he had like a trick but
Ah that's no not like this no that was
not what we needed where's wrong pieces
castling is good but not right okay so
he just lost with one move his accuracy
went down by 12 percent
that's so sad because he's probably so
proud like yes I'm castleing I'm doing
the principles no completely losing move
I'm not losing but not no not losing but
then he missed clicked wait
oh oh yeah yes
is he still a little bit better Cody on
the website guys a little bit
I meant to move my I didn't want to
Castle I wanted to move my castle right
here
thank you so can we unmute this man
right what happened he has touched this
King and now he went to move his Rook
and just that he's my next Prodigy
chess.com has done this to me they've
done this to me too they've done this to
me too I touch the king I don't want to
move the king anymore and then I I try
to go to the rook and it auto castles
you because the things that when you
touch your king and then touch your Rook
it once you're still gonna make it
happen though I love it yes look at this
very tilting I would be very tilted oh
my God better watch out.com
put this right here I'm gonna put my
look at that look at that look but he's
still doing it he gave her three moves
and the attack is still so strong that
he's gonna mate this is amazing
well there's uh what queen F4
no you made it on G2 sorry I've zoned
out wow just over
there's no way to defend
yeah wow Queen G3 I mean uh yeah five
you get a tax let's see if Jenny Jenny
needs to her only hope is to put a piece
on the sign of fire that's mate
uh okay
he wants style points he is too cool to
mate with the Queen the one mate with
the Rook he misses mate and now this is
made
but this is
King H1 he might lose the I mean
it's close it's very tight like you
gotta go here oh yeah Joanna gets kind
of tricky it's not that obvious
it depends where Junior's gonna go oh no
we're loose to find The Rook because she
has no other moves she has to take it
back he loses the Rook by force
and now he has to play Rook G8 is he
cerebral enough to recovery
yeah let's tune in I guess
let's see if he finds Rook G8
this is it this is the cherry on top
down mid am I right
I I think so you want to bring my other
Castle across
yes yes he's doing it oh my God
but he just came back stronger
oh my goodness
oh my goodness Rook to G8 on the board
oh my goodness let's go back to the full
screen we might wait did he play it he
played it yep you found it is he lagging
the odds are just against him today wait
wait what is going on it's not showing
up on my screen
oh God no not not the internet damn it
what
um it looks like he he disconnected
you're like no not the server speed down
oh no no stop man I don't want to work
day that's seven hours long what's going
on servers
too many people watching the game live
on chess.com
oh my god oh no this is
he was a move away from mate are refresh
oh my goodness
we'll be back at any second guys don't
worry
like he's used to Malden he plays Lee
he's he's prepared for this moment has
League crashed this league crash is that
a thing oh but I'm sure you know it
tilts them in other ways
I don't think
I don't know I only play this game I
really don't we got 100 seconds he's got
100 seconds on the clock he's gonna lose
on time oh my God
I mean I
I was I'm assuming we're okay I have
been instructed that we are going to be
we're going to have to take a short
break we got some technical difficulties
going on
I don't know we're gonna have an answer
for you all right let's take a short
break we'll be right back he looks best
[Music]
laughs
foreign
let's do a little bit of a stretch
whoa okay we're fine we're fine my dear
prank
I can do this I can do this I can do
this right here what are we doing here
what on Earth are we doing in this
position okay now we'll push our Pawn up
wait what we want oh you're kidding me
oh we're going to God okay okay we're
doing again nice okay people in the
night we're going to win a Night
okay that's good that's good that's a
cook right there we win a night you
little cook oh my goodness is this me
this okay we might go there I get a fork
on The Rook oh that's juicy oh that's so
juicy oh that's so juicy okay we focus
Rook we focus Rook I'm an idiot man
that's what I get for not playing chess
for 17 years
oh wait it's not me is that me okay boom
we go there oh yes come on
baby oh we can't we talked
[Music]
foreign
the process here because when you bring
out the bishop like this it can become
very vulnerable right away so I'm not
sure that I like the like the
variational approach here
no please don't
and it's too soon I can't believe it
it's too soon
he just lost
yes yes yes yes
Rook takes Knight and now Queen has two
queen g2s just game over like yeah and
oh and he's pointing up too oh no oh no
oh no
we have two logic misses it Queen F2
[Music]
what a throw
King E8 and then Queen C8 and there's
actually a staircase Checkmate oh man
watch it through maybe seven is made
Seven they're three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
so potentially be still made but no
Ludwig has no mercy literally 50 wait oh
there was increment I didn't realize it
was increment yes there's a two second
increments so three minutes plus two
second increment he has now collected a
lot of time and all the way up
[Music]
so again it's Charlie's moment he's got
to get the rest of the pieces out oh my
God he is Charlie's going off the defend
but frankly Jimmy's got 15 seconds
[Music]
he hung the house oh it's done mate it's
not just hanging The Rook it's mate
can we get the truth close call
Pikachu
no gifted Subs
[Music]
this is a very sad story
there's no way he is
oh my God why am I trying to get all
this pie this is where I was just about
to say it and it happened so fast oh my
God
foreign
[Music]
and sorry for the technical difficulties
chess.com servers took a bit of a dive
there but we're a new org these things
happen
yes
um and we're going to
pick up right where we left off that's
the good news the game is going to
resume the position is going to be the
same and the clocks are going to be the
same so it's going to be an absolutely
fair and Equitable well maybe Jenny
wants like a reset uh the position was
definitely a bit tough for uh for white
nothing the casters can do very sorry
about that and uh we had to sit there on
break just like all of you and wonder if
we're going to pick back up uh I should
have a game on my screen in a moment the
players have been informed
and uh yeah only drawback now is we're
running a little bit everyone these days
say that chess isn't up with the times
and like tired of being old school and
we thought if there was a couple lags
people you know would take a seriously
like video games these days
is that is that true dude yeah it's
giant it's just oh I don't know I think
I play games I don't know what I'm
making this [__] up certainly play more
video games than I do I feel like I
don't all I do is chess so you just
share it out you were like diamond in
OverWatch I can't even pass iron three
and valorant and that was it I couldn't
yeah Valor and Apex those are you know
those are stream games I play OverWatch
it's like an addiction that I don't want
to tell anybody that I have but I've
been clean for like two years I'm proud
of you I'm proud of you here if you ever
need to talk
no no I'm I'm all clean I'm I'm never
going back okay good
well the good news is
nothing really changes we just had a
little bit of a break I managed to turn
my air conditioner on and eat the rest
of my food
and uh
now so we we're gonna be going back to
the same position
same position this is nice like if if
you thought chess could be painful just
wait until your two moves from mate and
then we stall the maid out just so that
it hurts a little bit more once Tyler
made on the board to be honest I wish
shots.com would crash more when I was in
losing positions yeah it'd be cool if we
could Manifest this yeah but
unfortunately that's not really what
happens
so we will let you know when the game is
back up and running you will see it on
your screen
and let's not forget that yes
oh I was gonna say chess is the true
test of human patience not just the game
but we have um Jenny she's been
streaming for 13 hours and then Tyler
I'm not sure what he's been doing but
this is good now the real chess players
come out we'll see who we can break
first it's really just a test of
personal endurance
13 hours is crazy oh my God I would
never
I would never this is how you you train
chess you know have to have harder and
harder conditions this is what umdino
taught me oh I think we're checked
we're checking in on Tyler who whenever
the game start you will know in the
meantime uh this match is supposed to
start in 10 minutes
uh that's not gonna happen because the
first game of the previous match has not
started
uh the the second game rather the first
game of the previous match has not
concluded
um unless we're really evil and we just
make them play at that time anyway and
we just toggle back and forth but I
don't think we're going to be doing that
right
like the idea of chaos but yes no that
that would not be good or guys what if
they had like business meetings man it's
tough maybe you know it's like it's like
being the main event in a boxing or UFC
fight night like you just gotta wait you
gotta wait for everybody else yep and
then your friend comes and and stabs you
in the back and supports the opponent
yeah I I I also uh
I also just want to say that
Sea Dog is a thousand points higher
rated than cycuno yeah I I was gonna say
like you know yes we're we're stalling
and I'm sorry for the players and the
way but let's be honest I don't think
the next game is going to last that long
I'll say it the next matchup because
saikuno is just gonna destroy exactly
he's he's been training I don't know if
you saw but um he was doing some lessons
with Nemo last night and you don't want
to know what this guy's cooking up it's
it's pretty much over for Sea Dogs
there's not gonna be any Mercy for him
who is see those chess coach well Sea
Dog doesn't need one because he's kind
of been playing chess his entire life
and
um yeah I don't think he really trained
for this
he takes the event too lightly I mean I
got some real killers I'm not even sure
he's gonna make it out of his own group
with guys like Jarvis there that's true
you know I don't know what Sea Dog's
training was
I don't I don't think I mean listen he's
number one number two
uh xqc is very good definitely
unpredictable
uh somebody in the chat is saying we
want Frank
uh that yeah he's a little late to the
company guys don't worry I will arrange
there will be a Frank
S5
I will make it happen I will make sure
okay I I have just been informed that
the team is still setting up the
logistics for the game to resume
and so we are going to have to take
another short break
please do not be mad at me or Andrea we
do not control this we are simply The
Messengers but we will be right back and
Tyler won
versus Ginny TTY should resume
when we come back from the short break
thank you
foreign
[Music]
from what was promised to be a very
short break we have figured out all
technical difficulties on the back end
and we are ready to resume this fabled
match that this is the longest POG
Champs match that has ever ever occurred
Andrea I think this has been like 90
minutes for Tyler versus that's a way to
break history I told you they're
evolving yeah they're it's only been 22
moves but it's taken about an hour plus
um we are now five minutes away from our
second match of the day we're going to
take a look at Tyler we're not actually
Matt truth this match is not over yet
let's see what Tyler's got to say about
the situation
oh they've they've resumed
they've they've resumed it it seems like
they've resumed they're just gonna
adjust the clocks they resumed it just
just to get mated into moves for Ginny
man yeah
so now but she's down to a minute he
also had like
okay I guess he had three minutes when
he disconnected oh and the moment we've
all been waiting for guys I don't know
if you'll remember this it's been a long
time he might not see it Anything could
happen we are literally on the edge of
our seats oh my God Tyler put the queen
down Tyler if you don't know what you're
doing put the queen down stop touching
the queen
oh my God oh my God he's gonna see he's
gonna click a circle because they look
nice wait no no no no no wait why is
this okay Tyler we did not wait that
long for you to not play Checkmate oh my
goodness that we're gonna be here for
another 30 minutes delayed gratification
no there's there's no shot I just don't
know why he's thinking on it so much
there was a lot of time
oh my God oh my God you did not spend
this time thinking about his game I will
give you that if he doesn't end this
game now this thing might crash again
bro Tyler please just end this I want to
eat my dinner
and are suffering I was like no I was
200 sure I was even tuning in to stream
I was like yeah the man was so confident
the wait it says she's disconnected is
that what that says
oh no no well honestly this is
punishment this is deserved Tyler should
have found the mate I hope he has to
wait another 90 minutes okay
oh God I really hope this is not
oh my god oh man G2 was game over
this is this is legendary I've never
seen something like this the chess.com
servers don't want to let tyler1 win a
chess game this is ridiculous literally
against Tyler
oh my goodness there's no way there's no
way
chess cuts are just against this poor
man
wait she
it has a different position she doesn't
even have the same thing
she doesn't even see Queen H4
she just thinks he's thinking
oh this is some cruel prank
this is I bet you rob did I feel like I
feel like this is a Black Mirror episode
black one game abandoned oh no dude poor
Jenny like is this is so this is the
endless chess game this is it we are we
are living we are living in a Black
Mirror simulation this is just the chess
game that will never end you and I are
going to be sitting here for for days to
try to finish this test game that's all
I wanted ever in life just to sit and do
endless chess commentary
oh my goodness okay I've been told that
we're getting some sort of official
ruling I
I mean I imagine that was not her fault
it don't mess with tyler1 you know I
don't think I ever want to challenge
that guy to game of chess now wait I
have a question if he played if he
played Queen H4
but it never went on her screen was it
the official move like does can he play
a different move now okay I don't even
know we're not running that back again
I've been instructed that we are going
for another short break to figure out
the technical difficulties we will be
right back
[Music]
normal
let's go
[Music]
foreign
what's the first word that comes to your
mind uh the musical and of course the
board game fantastic okay it's just a
sport absolutely very competitive known
worldwide uh battle of wits to the
highest degree I imagine this is the
best interview I've ever given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
I appreciate it it's chess a sport
intellectually yes okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
it's like the game chess I can beat you
in chess if you beat me I'll give you
ten dollars ten ten if you beat me I bet
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I'm gonna let you do it I do
know what I'm doing I don't know what
I'm doing it's all right that's all
right I don't know what I'm doing in
life
okay
all right bro let's Checkmate oh
oh mate what's made bro I was
unbelievable you got 30 seconds for me
quick interview come on you look like a
chess player you play chess if I haven't
played chess okay when I say chess
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind winning
thank you
of these three things one of them is
real
chest dancing chess climbing chess
boxing chest climbing chest climbing
chest dancing climbing chess climbing
chess books chest boxing chess boxing
you nailed it okay am I right for real
you nailed it seriously yeah of of the
two of us one of us is a World Chess
boxing champion which one do you think
it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
no he's not I mean he does get he tried
to hit another guy earlier so
he looks oh my God she didn't even
hesitate from now on will you stop
making me do things in New York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord the process here because when
you bring out the bishop like this uh it
can become very vulnerable right away so
I'm not sure that I like the like the
variational approach here
no please don't
and it's too soon I can't believe it
it's too soon
he just lost
yes yes yes yes yes
[Music]
foreign
oh my gosh she just resigned Hikaru we
got a resignation it's going to the tie
break
take take apart oh boy boy image the
winner you won by the dirty flag the
question is does hafu take the Grand
Master approach here and just take the
professional for the championship
doesn't matter
you gotta listen in she's about to
deliver the goods
hard work pays off but now
foreign
[Music]
what was that
he's trying to no don't pre-move that
that is though sometimes oh my God he
could actually steal me oh this is a
really really bad the
do not do that because what is happening
stalemate if you do
you do the king might go the other way
buddy
oh oh my God
oh no never mind no box no no it's gonna
be a stalemate it's gonna be a stalemate
he's still
still though oh my don't do it he's
gonna do it don't do it don't do it oh
my God
[__] yeah I'll move like a staircase
yes click the Subscribe button see if it
says subscribe free and purple and if it
does you're golden Ponyboy anyway let's
check on who's priming right now
oh [__] it's my friend
um
Willis hey Willis can't wait to grab
lunch later catch you on the flippity
flip anyway back to the chess content
you guys have a good one if well
takes it you can't take back yeah
no
oh
[Music]
butthole the the check king of the king
and the queen of six right
did you do that what is wrong with you
Danny it's not me I said don't play
Queen F6
oh my gosh oh my God
oh my God
come on oh I didn't even realize they
started
they started and Charlie busts out the
uh the Dutch
the Dutch defends by Charlie and wait a
second has he pre-moved
yes he has
an entire King side development
those squares are moved with red have
you noticed Jimmy is making actual moves
have you seen
[Music]
wow he lets his eyes hold the treasure
in my hands
that's epic the future in my hands
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's the 2023 b-day World Championship
whose name will next be called champion
foreign
chest fever is on an Asana as the city
hosts the ultimate battle to Crown the
king of classical chess it's been a long
journey for the two challenges to the
halls of the Saint Regis Hotel and we
are live inside the playing Arena as we
wait for Yana pamushi and then learn to
arrive it's now the final stretch of the
video world championship match welcome
everyone I'm International Master Tanya
suchdev alongside me my co-commentators
Grandmaster Robert Hess and a
Grandmaster Fabiano caruana four games
remain
leads with one point thing Lauren has to
strike back to equalize right off the
bat Fabi what's the one thing you're
expecting from ding today
I don't know if it's so much expecting
but I think that he is in a position now
when we're getting close to the end of
the match when maybe it's time to take
some extra risks and we've seen these
players both take risks during these
matches during this match but in the
last few games they've played rather
quietly steadily but ding is still down
a point and he doesn't want to let it
get to that you know final few games
when he's in a muslin situation I think
he should try to take the chance now to
get some chances
as we get closer to the Finish Line in a
14-game match each match becomes that
much heavier the pressure increases the
margin for error at this point for ding
lyron is zero he needs to win a game
looking good with every passing game he
gets closer to becoming world champion
Robert what will Beyond's approach today
well you say the margin for error for
dingly rent is nearly zero the number of
Errors yesterday was pretty much zero
and for Yonder Palm she I think it's
going to be more of the same why should
he take any risk why does he need to do
anything different he should play his
solid steady approach another draw will
not be a bad result from especially
because there's a rest day tomorrow and
then he can prepare to have the black
pieces in the 12th round
a draw in this match would mean that Ian
just goes steps closer to that world
championship title while for ding it
would mean one game less to strike back
so much at stake the start of the world
championship match this first half was a
fist fight with five decisive games
starting from a game two and then we saw
four back-to-back victories with the
white pieces but going into the second
half we see the players treading more
cautiously they are taking less risks
and playing with incredibly high
accuracy as we saw starting from game
eight it was a draw 3 back to backdraws
in game 10 once again with the white
pieces we saw Tingler and push exert
pressure but Ian had a principal
approach to defense and though ding
tried Fabi it was never close to being
enough
yeah we yesterday we saw a nearly
perfect one could even say perfect game
of chess but at the moment ding doesn't
want perfect games or chess he wants a
mess he wants some blood as tell said
you want to take your opponent into a
deep dark forest and that's what ding
needs at the moment he really needs to
get back into into the equality of the
match and then you know what we'll see
in the final few games but I think it
would be very difficult for him if we're
going to the final game of the match and
he needs to win you know white pieces or
not you you don't have
amazing chances of winning a single game
against a player as strong and as well
prepared as young and probably she's so
every game is a chance I think he should
try be trying to create complications
and you know a way for his opponent to
make mistakes yeah I think for ding he
needs to make the most of his chances
but he's just not gonna get them I'm
sorry to say I know Chad's going to hate
me but I expect a d word a draw today I
think that's what is likely because
yonda palmchi he wants to Coast through
to the Finish Line he sees it it's
within his sight so why should he take
any risk he has the white pieces if he
can liquidate if he can make a draw I
think he's gonna do that
it questions how much will Yan push with
why Tingler and will he be under
pressure one more time with the black
pieces and will he be able to hold for
it it was a confident hold in a game
plan by Jan napomnushi and this is what
ding had to say about the outcome of the
game
today I drew another white game
so it means
there are only four games left
I need to at least
score one wins to level the score it's
become quite normal like there are three
draws
in the three drones okay there the
tournaments do not finish yet
so okay we still have four games left I
wouldn't say I was how much confidence
am I now I didn't consider that
four games left two with with the white
pieces for dangler and confidence will
be a big factor in this one and as we
can see our chesscom stats team has
given these odds based on the outcome
the result of today's game 11. it's
going to be a big exciting day of chess
if Jana Palmer she with the white pieces
wins essentially it won't just be game
over it will be match over it's nearly
impossible tingling will need the
biggest of Miracles to come back from a
two-point deficit a 98 favorite for
yandere with a draw still more than an
80 favorite and if thing strikes back
with the black pieces our stats team
actually edges inches more towards ding
with a 47 to Jana pamushi looking at
these stats Robert is it fair to say
that for ding it's more important to
keep things under control to not take
extra risk than to try for a win today
with black yeah for a dingley ren he
gets two whites in the remaining three
games after today we've seen him create
Chances with the white pieces not
yesterday but in game eight that results
may have been a draw but he was winning
so as you said confidence will be
important for him I think he should
confidently try to neutralize the
opening advantage today and then he
could take it from there
easier said than done Robin with
janapanushi starting with the white
pieces it is all going to come down to
what is Yan's approach today will he be
the one who tried to close off the match
today maximize his chances try to create
Chaos on the board but the drawback of
that strategy would be that Ding perhaps
could get his moments in the game and
Strike Back well it's been a fascinating
World Championship with so many decisive
games with the black pieces we've seen
only one win so far and it was back in
game two with janapamnishi drawing first
blood in the match with a fantastic win
with black apart from that we've often
seen in the match the player playing
Black has struggled to neutralize out of
the opening now Jan hasn't lost a single
game in this match with black thing
meanwhile not just in this match with
the black pieces
thing has not yet defeated janapamnushi
in this world championship match as well
as any of the classical games that
they've played against each other
Robert is not gonna have a psychological
effect on ding going into today's game
yeah ding has not beaten the under Palm
shoe with the black pieces I don't think
he is going to be aiming for that today
if an opportunity arises he will try to
make the most of it but you could see
Jana palmchi there same salmon colored
shirt same strong mental fortitude same
fantastic chess player as we've seen
throughout this world championship so
for ding he knows his opponent at this
point and he knows that he can't just
drum up a win out of nowhere he would
have to take some serious risk and I
just don't think ding dude needs to do
that at this late stage he still has two
white games remaining I don't think now
is the time to let things go crazy
just four games remaining two getting
our 17th Chess World Champion Fabi are
you surprised to see Yan return with a
pink shirt or not as much
well I I'm not as his stylist but if I
were I would tell him you know maybe to
try out a different color you know they
say uh variety is a spice of life so
let's see some different colors for
these last few games but I think that uh
these last few games will be very
interesting as you said Jan has never
lost to ding with the white pieces and
that's very relevant
but I still think that Ding should try
to take his chances you know just
because things haven't happened in the
past doesn't mean that they can't happen
today or or potentially in the remaining
black game that they will have and I
want to push back a little bit on what
Robert said because
even though we have seen didn't create a
lot of Chances with the white pieces I
feel like it is possible he has
exhausted his repertoire of ideas with
white and that might be why we saw the
last game he he didn't he wasn't fully
perfectly prepared for this bishop C5
move that Jan came out with and I feel
like he's he's trying to you know probe
a little bit in in various directions
trying to find some sort of weaknesses
in Jan's opening repertoire but he might
have already used his main ideas in the
earlier stages in this match
[Music]
interesting because even though the
price of the press conference sting
actually confessed to
being out of his preparation by move
nine with that move Bishop C5 that you
mentioned by Yan we've seen ding come up
with these very combative energetic
opening surprises but then with a one
slight deviation by Yan which perhaps is
not the top move it feels as if ding
tends to go into a thing and finds
himself out of his familiar preparation
Robert has that surprised you a little
bit the fact that Ding is the one who is
playing these amazing variations and
these different openings but very
quickly is also the one who goes into a
think tank
well to push back against Fabiano's
pushback here we're good friends we can
argue sometimes I think that dink said
to himself that he was interested in
Risk minimization because of the
critical moment when he took that pawn
on D6 yesterday and traded Queens he
could have dropped his Bishop back
that's actually what Fabiano was
recommending that would have provided
him more winning chances he seemed a bit
nervous he just wanted to get down to
the end game where he couldn't possibly
lose nothing could go wrong there so I
feel to answer your question directly
Tanya has been a bit surprising but I
think that Ding diren has shown his
emotions I think that he has been quite
upfront with everybody watching that he
is nervous that things aren't going
exactly his way but he still is within
the territory where he can win this
match he's only one point behind and as
we see the players getting seated there
in the in Kazakhstan I mean dingley red
he knows what he needs to do today and
that is not loose
I'm gonna push back on both of you
pushing back and say that definitely for
a world championship preparation things
prep today has to not lack that debt he
cannot afford to burn the clock early on
Jan playing with the white pieces thing
has to be sure that he has those
critical minutes uh reaching time
control reaching move 40 it is something
that Yan can play on by not taking too
much risk perhaps in the opening stages
but making sure that he poses the big
question when the clock runs low we see
both players seated I'm expecting the
jackets to come off meticulously be
placed uh on the chairs first moves are
about to happen and of course that begs
the question to be asked one E4 by n is
that a mutual vote
I'm gonna go with yes I think E4 I don't
think it's time to experiment Rihanna
because
as as you guys both pointed out he's
he's in the lead and there's no reason
to take unnecessary risk uh you know
you're in the lead of course you're
playing with the white pieces and I
think Jan will still have some ambition
of course in this game but he's not
going to want to put himself in a
position where he's potentially losing
the game that would be a complete
disaster and putting not only back in
the match but arguably as a favorite
especially you know uh in the
psychological sense because winning with
the black pieces and such a crucial game
that would be so huge psychologically
and in the match score so I think E4 and
you know what I hope to see I don't know
if I expect it but I hope to see a
sicilian night or
you actually said that yesterday if Abby
and Robert you were quite amused with
that prediction uh at the close of the
show after game 10 and I have to ask you
what are the chances of us actually
seeing a night off today Robert
yo this is one where I trust Fabi and I
think that it would be excellent to see
a night or and I just want to say I
agree completely with what fabi's been
saying and I'm looking at this game I'm
looking at the opening stage Jan has had
advantages with the white pieces let's
not forget that two games ago in game
nine Jan actually had an advantage and
he was disappointed with that draw so he
is an ambitious player if the situation
occurs where he can play for an edge he
will do just that but he wants to
minimize his own risk the players I mean
they're seated they're ready I think
that dingley Ren he's looking at this
board intently and I think we should all
intently wait for his first move because
if it's C5 it's a sicilian Bobby you're
gonna be a proud proud commentator
colleague of dingly red
oh I I will be super proud but you know
I don't know what I would do if I was in
his position it's easy to say play the
Sicilian go all out you know try to take
advantage of perhaps Jan's
um uncertainty in terms of should I play
for a win should I play it solidly that
is a sort of vulnerable psychological
state where you can try to uh and here
we see the first move E4
played not a surprise but will Yan
because he's not obligated to to uh play
the
that first move he's taking it back will
he uh
[Music]
welcome back everyone thank you so much
for your patience uh the back end devs I
think that's the right technical term if
not then the emergency team Mission
Control have been up to the task and it
seems as though the servers have
stabilized Andrea how did you spend your
last 20 minutes
yes
yes I finished my food uh I got my water
here I went outside I sat on the
were you muted
oh I've lost my co-host
all right well
hello chat it's uh it's uh it's me it's
it's me uh it's uh it's the tyler1
stream I think he's also watching the
stream Tyler I'm sorry I didn't do this
but
um
I guess I also can't really talk about
the game okay I refreshed uh I'm not
muted in there I suppose that would be
providing unfair Insight it was a really
good game
and oh I think I think I got my co-host
back oh we got we got Ginny on the
screen now
kidding guys debating
there was no one's allowed to know what
I did during the break it was a secret
if there was one participant who I would
not want to be mad at me I think it's
Tyler
yeah
I have to say I've been kind of
entertained tuning in between the two
because I've also just been waiting
um but Tyler is very funny at some point
he was ranting at why the stalemate rule
exists if you're up a drastic amount of
pieces so I was definitely enjoying the
Tyler tangents
oh I did not have a chance to enjoy
those I
all I've been told is that the game will
be resuming momentarily and every now
and then I look at the I look at the
side over here and they put us on full
screen so I'm like cracking my Knuckles
thinking and then it turns out that
actually I'm up there
um so Tyler had a very big attack going
uh against Ginny's King and then he
disconnected and then they told us we
were coming back and then we we're not
coming back and then we did come back
and then he played a move
and then and then she disconnected and
then that's been our longest break since
so it's very easy for chess.com to
resume the game uh with the same amount
of time in the exact same position
the hard part is guaranteeing that their
servers stay up but I think they've
actually I think the game
I don't have the game yet but we're
gonna go look all right moment of truth
there it is
wow
I never thought I'd see that position
again yeah I was kind of hoping I
wouldn't
yeah Queen a queen H4 was the recent
move and uh now it's Ginny's move I
believe
I believe it's Jenny's move this is the
this is the best chess game I've ever
seen Queen to C3 check she's had 20
minutes to come up with a move by the
way yeah let's not forget I was curious
what they were gonna spend their time on
I think that they're both trying to make
a plan
um we'll see what they came up with
you spent all this time calculating and
coming up with great plans
no Queen C3 yeah he he he's got he's got
a little bit of extra time I mean we're
we're back in game mode here uh she can
um
she well she's not she can she is giving
him a check and he's got multiple ways
of blocking he could literally block
with every Pawn uh one is better than
the other
one is worse than the other and one is
they're they're all probably oh he's
trying he's picking up the F Pawn just
imagine if Ginny comes back and ends up
winning this game I I think after that
would make history yeah after all of
that I mean I I would just I'd be done I
mean I've been done kind of but uh yeah
all right he he's he's thinking about it
he has played E5 it's on the live board
but you're about to see it over there
I'm I'm waiting for the move because I
don't want to destroy the stimulation
simulation
yeah he's a little bit behind there it
is she's got less than a minute let's
throw it up on the big screen here
uh wow that's a great move by her she's
gonna trade The Rook off and then it's
just gonna be an end game
and
I mean
yeah
then I don't know Tyler Heather doesn't
really have any choice here it's just
I'm gonna come back and remind him later
that he could have ended all of our
suffering about 30 minutes ago
yeah yeah he could have uh he he had
Checkmate in one uh two twice he had
checked me to one he could have checked
me on the G2 Square two times actually
oh if any of you are wondering what am I
still doing here just remember Tyler won
Checkmate in one but you know blame
tyler1 yep exactly just kid don't do
that you'll come for me and has much
bigger arms than me even though I
provoke most streamers and say I can
beat them in a fight maybe not Tyler
uh that would be a fun addition to
anybody that's probably the only
streamer I won't take out an essend
anesthet but why I would take a husband
um I've worked out with him and he just
slightly benches a little a little bit
more than me but not by a lot
is that sarcasm does he events like 300
pounds or I don't know you have to get
in the gym with us to find out Levy
ah I see
uh yeah well you never know I mean Tyler
could gasp you know he's got huge
muscles he's got to keep them fueled I
don't exactly know what this queen
maneuver is but it's going to safety
Queen takes D4 wait a minute could be an
issue okay Tyler's not in oh no Ginny's
not interested
well she's actually you know what let's
just she's coming back she's defending
that Chad is saying s fan can do 300
pound bench press 15 times that's
extremely impressive wow that's
Sensational ah it's mate
is the moment the the game that won't
end seriously
okay the good news is this is the only
move and Knight takes Queen is made by
accident Knight takes Queen is made by
it's over
all right that was a good one late Jenny
looks actually like horrified
tyler1 wins the game three times that's
okay third time's the charm okay I think
it's about five times is that normal
hahaha
what is happening bro I don't know what
that means what is that you get time
randomly additive a game I think it went
on time
he's not even happy about his mate he
doesn't know the time oh he doesn't
understand why the time keeps going up
plus five seconds no reaction to this
Checkmate of this 90 minute game
that's not the reaction I was expecting
but I am thoroughly entertained
and and after that colossal one and a
half hour Battle of a 10 minute game
Group C has an early leader in tyler1
leading one nil over Ginny now we're
gonna get the second game going quickly
for obvious reasons uh Tyler is now
going to get a game with the white
pieces and we'll see how that one goes
um any predictions for an opening
you know I I don't want to predict but
um I just want to say to everyone who's
still tuning in and to the talent Jenny
and Tyler thank you guys and we
appreciate your patience and we know
it's because you really really really
love chess and are really excited to be
here and yes we appreciate you guys not
because first place is 20 000.50 it's
definitely that that it's because you
love chess I love chess and then
right now
yes same same uh this was actually a
very good game I have to say before the
disconnect and before the Miss
checkmates in one uh and we already have
game two underway so let's get us off
the screen D4 Knight A6 now this
obviously you know you want to play for
the center with the pawns and the
Knights which is exactly what uh Tyler's
doing Knight A6 has been played quite a
bit by you know strong players like
Carlson and ah yes you think she brushed
up on her Magnus Theory yeah she's
playing the Australian defense has Ginny
actually streamed from Australia I
wouldn't be surprised maybe she's
preparing for I did a thing he's uh he's
the only Australian in the group
so this is a real opening and you're not
trolling people actually play Knight A6
F5
no def they definitely don't play a five
but after a five it's kind of a Dutch
defense it's D4 F5 and then Knight C3
Knight A6 I mean it's edgy stuff you
know it's it's not cutting edge Theory
but you know I have four of each
blocking in the bishop a little bit now
black is just fantastic there you go
she's making it work she did go to
Australian stream that's awesome
honestly if I can stream in one place it
would be Australia because there's lots
of animals and it's probably the most
dangerous place
yeah there's a lot of animals like
spiders and jellyfish
and uh snakes and so on one day oh I can
I could see you fighting a kangaroo yeah
me too Alex wanted to go do a boat as a
broad episode and be professional spider
Hunters always hunt the most dangerous
spiders
maybe that'll be my next calling
that that that is USA literally has guns
there
I'm talking about the animals we're not
oh she's undeveloped the night uh she
was not convinced of the night's
positioning on the edge of the board
um she really she she should try to get
more pieces into the game so what I tell
beginners is like nine times out of ten
going backwards is not the best move
um you've got a better move going
forward
curious if Tyler could maybe prepare
some made on the F7 I don't think it's
doable but I see a world where it could
happen
yeah you don't know if if he has that um
in his toolbox right like you don't if
you're a beginner you might not be
thinking Checkmate Tyler doesn't need a
toolbox he just has his straight guns he
he is the toolbox yeah exactly
he is the toolbox I wonder if he ever
gets tired of being objectified well now
he knows what it's like to be a female
on Twitch
Yes except they yeah I I don't I don't
know if they laude the the biceps
because he's got he's got um but uh she
brought the Knight to C6 which is better
I wish she did that sooner
uh okay
and now now little Center balls a little
Bishop
I see a master plan by Tyler Knight G5
coming in and he's going to made on F7
I'm telling you
yeah night night here night here Bishop
here
this this could be Redemption from from
what happened
or he'll just Castle let's see is he
gonna be aggro Bishop F7
okay I don't know if Jenny will see it
Knight G5 would have been a little
trickier but this is great because yeah
like you showed with the arrows D6 does
not defend the mate because the Knight
will still take the other Escape Square
from the King
yeah wow this is crazy I mean I'm
assuming she's gonna take because like
she just put the Knight there and this
night is coming so now she sees this
she's like oh almost easy get rid of
that
uh I don't know I wouldn't make any
assumptions at this point I think could
happen I kind of want to see a juicy
mate
not because not because today took
longer than usual but because I'm very
excited for a juicy mate
yeah yeah juicy oh we're apparently
looking in on Tyler's tyler1 stream
right now
what's he up to
I have no idea about what that's gonna
happen I have no idea we're kind of
moving this one
if you can't move these you can't move
these can't move that this is the mate
right back should go here
she can take this don't know it wasn't
just a coincidence did I
kind of feeling like I deseed not gonna
lie
oh my God there is literally is that not
a free Queen with Knight F7 trap the
queen yes let's yes let's show this on
the board so Knight E5 was not just
threatening Bishop F7 made which is
normally the move that you you don't you
you oh oh he didn't want the queen or me
yeah that's made uh but you but that's
no longer made but that's a free Queen
because it's completely trapped that
would have been a nice one
instead he went D5 and now if the
servers disconnect we're gonna be here
for another 50 moves the bishop is
blocked uh but this is still defended
he's still doing very very well
um
but Knight F7 was a clean triple fork
for tyler1 hitting the queen and the
Rook at the bishop but oh
do some puzzles
ah ping maybe moves maybe we even get
that Knight back in F7 unless you block
oh and he did he did just play this so
it's a natural follow-up for Tyler and
like he said he knows what he's doing I
think he's gonna take the knights
I yeah I don't know I mean he just went
here he was threatening to take the
Knight
I I think
I took the Knight what a beast
this is good I was really starting to
get worried like
I know he plays League of Legends and he
likes the pain but you have to take the
piece at some point
uh does Jenny know it's a discover check
like does she she's gonna try to take
this and then the thing is gonna go me
like it doesn't change
all right F7 you you would sack The Rook
but you know it's it's a cheat y Fork
Knight F7 is
the best move it picks up a rook or or
more if black doesn't take you can I
don't know Tyler didn't see it earlier
so might not happen yeah he just keeps
taking here's the here's my problem with
this move you're you're giving your
opponent's Bishop way too much scope
is activating the sniper indeed
but why but what The Rook can be taken
and oh no that he's gotta quit on the
board he's a magician doesn't need the
mate he doesn't need the queen he
doesn't need anything the man just
promoted and moved like 15. yet the pawn
just walked through it couldn't be taken
on C6 it needed to be taken on B7 yeah I
listen a bit of fatigue for sure also
isn't Jenny in Europe it's 1 40 in the
morning very late for Ginny very very
late poor guys that's not nice that
we've solved the match out I mean he's
got a queen now he's got a
he's he's got a he's gotta keep the
queen safe there are two queens just
standing around
so Knight C6 is clean
yeah she thought she was in check
all right we've got some feedback she
was definitely not in check two moves
ahead visualizing the Knight on F7 but
it happens it happens it's all good
and uh chess is hard
chess is hard what can you say and he
castles clean move from Tyler look okay
no the a7's defended I would say there
is a chance we take that Queen but
there's there's not any chance okay
no
oh she needed to make sure that Knight
was defended I mean the queen was at the
Knight was not defended I can't even
speak anymore
oh now there's two queens versus nothing
I think Tyler's also speedrunning I'm
sure he's gonna play like six four hours
of League after this right I think at
this point Jenny's just trying to flex
she's like yeah I want to see how many
queens you can make Tyler
I I think she's flexing that he doesn't
know how to mate and that he's just
gonna keep making a ton of Queens it's
really just an elaborate mind game and I
think this has been all calculated
that is that is certainly a theory let's
put it this way yes he's gonna make a
third Queen
I think he's just gonna start taking as
much free stuff as possible Queens
really open up your your eyes to
Tactical patterns and
your queen can see that they're full as
as long as she doesn't block she also
might think she's in check so she has to
move her King and that's the only legal
move and then he will swoop in with the
second Queen and then he shall make a
third
because why not oh no
oh he took the bishop though yep yep
when you see a rook take a bishop
yeah the bishop was over uh the only
reason that the queen could take was
because the bishop was defending the
Rook or rather attacking
and this is a very convincing game from
Tyler very very convincing second game
here
um
now he's got to get he can take the Rook
he could also get a second Queen in
what's gonna happen here
I don't know why but Tyler still looks
so stressed but I also can't tell
because of his intense gaming
maybe I'll just commentary from down
here for the rest of the day he's on
fire I mean he is listen he's got the
real you have you ever seen these chess
players on camera in the speed Chess
Championship I mean it's ridiculous it's
a forehead I have not but you know life
seems better from this angle I might
just take on the rest of the broadcast
I want a third Queen
yeah I mean this is
not getting the third Queen he wants to
end the chest as fast as possible and
then he wants to he wants to go back to
his real job and that's where you're
wrong Levy we don't have real jobs he
literally said that I'm quoting Tyler
yeah no I know
Ponte there's got to be a mate I mean
you could get the Rook you could you
could get in here with the Queen's two
queens are super powerful get them on
the back rank a little corner Checkmate
coming I think Jenny is gonna strategy
tie up all her pants
and Orient orientate the queens in a
perfect structure
all she has to do is get rid of these
pawns and she is she's getting this tell
me I can't even this Chestnut come
overlay I'm looking at I can't even tell
how much material he's up how much
material is white up
a lot
I legitimately can't tell okay I didn't
go to I didn't go to college for a
reason don't make me do more math than I
have to
all right black has nine points this is
nine right here so it's 5 10 19 24 oh
it's more than that now 28. thanks Chad
I do math when you have human computers
look at that look at this setup for the
ladder mate oh look at that setup for
the ladder mate oh my God Mrs stalemate
by just a second this is crazy
a second some pawns that was a very
clear bonds and stuff
that was a very clean and convincing
game
yeah baby
and you guys two numbers
straight by the way nine straight
he won nine straight games for parents
yes sir yes sir I told you when the
pressure is on I perform who cares about
all those games throughout the week I
was warming up bro at
I can still hear him uh Tyler won with a
monster performance the first 2-0 of the
day both other matches had at least one
draw he never left any doubt and I gotta
tell you I was prepared I was looking at
everyone's Scouting Report before the
event and he's an underdog in group C
but after this performance I'm not sure
I mean he's knocking on the door for xqc
squeaks is gonna have to be looking out
Tyler won Tyler won if he endured this
90 minute match I really think he can do
anything you might just win the whole
tournament xqc better watch out
xqc Sea Dog everybody in in in in uh
Tyler's group that was a really really
masterful performance also good job
keeping the composure uh and uh yeah I
mean if he just fine-tunes a couple
things plays the openings just the tiny
little improvements here and there we
might have uh we might have a dark horse
to win POG Champs five
um the match that would never end has
officially come to a conclusion uh can I
finally get some sleep now after 14
hours thank you Jenny you're a real one
we appreciate you
yes apparently uh Jenny has been
streaming for 14 hours hopefully she
also gets some rest we are going to take
a short break not due to technical
difficulties but because we are
preparing for our final match of the day
which is Sea Dog versus saikuno and we
will see you on the other side of this
very short break
[Music]
the the check king of the king and the
queen of six right
Danny why did you do that what is wrong
with you Danny it's not me I said don't
play Queen F6
oh my gosh oh my God
oh my god
oh yes come on your subscription makes
shows like this possible which is why
our twitch subscribers will never see
ads on chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Masters can then lose 10 pounds and burn
6 000 calories just by sitting yeah so
I've actually been spending a lot of
time getting in shape wow that's great
what are you doing mostly like Rook
lifts oh I've never heard of that it's a
thing don't look it up
oh
[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
our final match of day number one of
pogchamps five it's been quite a day
we've had battles in group a group b
Group C and now we are going back to
group a to finish the day off with sea
dog versus saikuno uh Andrea how's uh
how's your day been how's your uh your
coverage it's the best day ever I got to
spend more time with my BFF Gotham chess
and really big fan so I just really
treasured every hour today
yeah same yeah
um particularly no uh bad joke uh I I
forgot there was a disconnect I was
gonna say uh you know you know I I
really you know enjoyed my time solo but
it's it's been a long day
um jokes aren't funny when you have to
explain them
yeah uh we've got one more matchup for
you today I'm tired
this this match was supposed to take
place an hour ago I love how the start
time moves that's so slick they moved
the start time from seven to eight oh
you guys are you guys are sneaky it was
it was 7 P.M Eastern Time
Productions doing their best did you see
the king Crusher video that they had I
have to say that was that was a nice
touch I liked that one that's I I did
not I just laid on the couch
uh no I got a lot of love and respect a
Sea Dog Champion let's let's see let's
check in on him how he's doing
I don't know if we have audio I bet all
the students use all this extra time to
prepare for these games
so that means that audio the next level
chest that we're gonna see is gonna be
through the roof it's gonna top
everything you've seen today
yes this is by far the most lopsided
matchup that we have had uh saikuno is
coming in at a hot and fiery and spicy
199 ELO the 99s they they have a special
charm to them I have to tell you Tyler
with the 199. I I think this could be a
lucky thing wasn't I think Tyler was
250. uh someone no no he was no no he
was 99 or maybe I'm seeing things I
don't remember it maybe his opponent
someone was 199. you started the morning
at 199. saikuno is a is is a massive
massive deal he uh he he does a ton of
uh different variety gaming content and
chess like is one of these things that
if you don't do all the time
your ELO won't go up naturally it's
something you have to do for hours and
hours so he agreed to play in the event
which means
we really should have given him a
tune-up match I mean whoever made this
matchup is just brutal when 200 you're
not supposed to play it will just
demoralize you his goal today should be
to get to a good position and 15 20
moves
and not lose that's the goal
um well I mean it it's you said it Levy
it is gonna be a tough one but you know
maybe Sea Dog will take it easy I
couldn't got a very strong audience got
a lot of fans you know Sea Dog might not
want to mess with him the girlies could
come after him that's true that's true
Ricky Waters here listen the only way
sea dog loses this game uh is uh is just
arrogance right and wait saikuno Zelo
was 104.
wait the game just
he told me he was 200 a couple days ago
oh man
oh saikuno I love it I love this I think
he's smurfing I think he's got a secret
account rated 1200 Knight F3 confident
move from Connor
I don't know I'm very excited to see
what saikuno has planned for today he's
the underdog but I believe in him I
think he'll he'll take it away this is
the petroff defense from saikuno and
Connor's losing Conor's losing oh he was
losing
he he actually hung his Pawn there that
was the same game as Frank versus Jarvis
uh but saikuno did not take uh looks
like he's going for the solid copycat
strategy yep it's a copycat opening
copy him just copy him saikuno I mean
he's doing what you're doing just there
there you go if he's 1100 this is this
is the way
wow look at that
nice Pawn to D6 now Conor might go here
and then it's like Uno should just copy
him
just copy him this is only gonna work
for so long until they take the Knight
on F6
yes it's true if you copy until
Checkmate wow oh god oh no okay I wonder
how far
listen yes
this is perfect stuff like
if you can't beat him do exactly what
they do
no this is this is good I like this
genius stuff Connor's gonna malfunction
Connor's gonna do some crazy taikuno has
has outsmarted the opponents
oh yeah look at this is that gamer shed
okay now Cyclone's got to be careful he
can't go here because that'll loosen the
game
please don't copy you gotta take the
Knight here sakuna Sea Dog realizes
what's happening he's trying to make it
tricky for him
yeah if saikuna goes here he's going to
lose his Rook
and his Queen
wow
all right he has broken the spell
now will he find Knight D4 castles don't
hate it although Knight D5 is now
winning for white with the pressure it's
why you got to be careful about these
pins oh what he played that in like half
a second holy [__]
well yeah
yeah that's why he's 1180. wow and now
he's threatening this hit the queen
Checkmate that's why you gotta PP on the
pp put pressure on the pin piece
PP on the pp is that what you just said
I hear that right uh yep yep
yep Knight takes F6 and that's
okay that's also oh my God he wants to
use the Knight to attack the king
he might even be trickier maybe trying
to go for a mate too
yeah it was better to stick with the
bishop but as long as he doesn't play
Queen takes as long as he doesn't do a
little Queen takes here Knight takes F6
uh there's a way you could lose he could
go Knight F6 King here and then Queen F5
and hang his Knight that would be crazy
case thinking
yeah I know I'm sure he's he's gonna
hang his Knight Versa 100
oh oh whoa
okay all right mixing it up okay
only down upon but back into the game if
he trades Queens if he trades Queens but
I don't know if he's gonna trade he
might go here if he doesn't oh yes
wow yes yes let's go this is good
Connor just go into the end game here
against the 104. a lot of respect here
shown a little bit scared of saikuno's
capabilities in the middle game so now
he can go here or come back
there is no Fork
yeah unfortunately Knight D7 looks like
maybe you could potentially trap the
Knight and saikuno could come back but
it doesn't work this is a good move too
hopefully we can maybe defend the pawn
on C7 oh wow I like the counter attack
even more I think it's crazy I said
tsikuno's got to get to 20 moves and not
be losing he's made it 13 moves and okay
this is taking that does not guarantee
much I mean The Rook is open but right
now is where the 100 might be on display
right like if you're 100 it means you
just haven't built up the experience of
middle games 100 has a lot less to do
with your actual abilities and oh my God
I would underestimate the 100 saikunos
got this in the bag what a beautiful
move that's a great move and if Knight
C7 the The Rook just traps the Knight I
was gonna say it just has to do with
experience he just hasn't played that
much so yeah he's uh the knights gotta
go back
he'll be tuned into saikuno I'd love to
hear his thoughts
I mean you never really know I guess
um
okay
it's always so calm this is like Eric
Rosen in an alternate universe they're
the same person
he's taking a long time guys look at it
look at the time here I've got a whole
minute on him neither of us are running
low on time but if it comes down to it
we we have a whole minute on him he's
only got seven
minutes left so like at this point I
don't know if he's just lagging or but
the confidence is there for being
against someone one thousand points
higher than you I guess
dumb
I mean I feel like you just have to move
this horse right I'm just trying to
trade this Pawn for a free horse which
is like
I I feel like he has to move it but he
doesn't seem like he wants to I
maybe there's something I'm missing but
I feel like it's an obvious move you
just get this horse out of the way
okay so that's what I thought he would
do
um and now
I'm going to do this
because that'll oh wait is this guy in
danger I wasn't paying attention but
it's it's whatever okay
and now he has to move his uh Crown man
I believe
uh right
I think he has to move the crown man and
then I'm going to move whoa whoa you
could do that it's getting tricky oh you
can't move your crown man like that okay
I mean well you can I just didn't think
you would because that's a crazy move
um
well I I guess I'll just have to move my
horse back hey he's saving his life
looks pretty safe he's handling this
very well that was a wild smoothie stuff
yeah wild move he did that
um
by the way uh Andrea that's what your
mic is supposed to sound like I don't
know what my mic sounds like no I think
you have the same mic but his sounds
I I don't really we'll work on it
uh apparently the move that he just
played is bad but I don't really
understand why
uh like
yeah his his like he he's uh why is that
a bad move ah I think I okay I could be
completely wrong
um but I was thinking a plan like A4
kick out the night night at five check
and then white has a D4 plus never mind
forget the whole but it was a whole plan
to push D4
but it's gone now
actually still possible with night check
actually you're saying the idea was
takes takes here here it takes takes and
then after this there's takes and then
there's takes but there is takes
yeah well but I I actually you can still
do the plan just push before this is
still a decent plan with night check
right here yep take take
your
take check I'm sure he sees every single
one of these
uh Connors Connor's good enough to see
take take in the Knight of five check
for sure because he's definitely seeing
this
um okay car is on vacation so someone
else has to do the arrows now okay this
is the new Hikaru
everyone welcome your king
am I the crown man okay funny he doesn't
play it I mean this is just firing moves
he just does not care I mean rookie ate
so fast
good move that night is a god it's just
gonna live there forever or it's gonna
go here
and even yep
sees it it's like who know my move is
yep he doesn't that's gonna be there in
two seconds
three
boom yep
yep
I have to say first level he was really
doing great but this is what deciphers
the difference between 100 1000 yeah
pretty solid play so far but just takes
one blender
yeah he just got a little bit lost in
the middle game but again his opponent
is just really experienced really good
and I kind of I I don't I this is this
was not a nice matchup like she Connor
should have played Frank or something
like I don't know this was very mean uh
but if sakuna wants to try super hard in
the next few weeks he just has to grind
a lot of puzzles
a lot of puzzles and some basic openings
and I think he'll get to 5 600 easily
good luck
well you know based on saikuno's Strat
of counting the time he's doing really
well in on that other game on the clock
he is up a whole almost
two minutes
yeah he well he's definitely up to he's
he was trying to be a more his time is
sticking down now yep uh yeah
unfortunately a rook and a bishop are
just not enough here because the king is
totally safe uh Conor would have to
blunder something really terrible
and even if he blunders let's say a rook
for a bishop
unfortunately he's just gonna have the
upper hand in the end game but
and that's also just the Free Pawn you
could just take that
yeah I really I genuinely would love to
see saikuno grind chess I do think he
has the Mind friend I hope this matchup
doesn't discourage him because it is
intense wow wait wait oh it's like Uno
had a chance
he could have played Pawn takes Rook
takes Bishop Fork but unfortunately he
goes backwards and also Conor didn't
have to do that yeah he probably
wouldn't take the pawn but it was it
would have been a nice attempt
yeah now Conor can just
or his legal name Sea Dog VA or actually
his legalshows.com name which is Chad
dog VA I like that do you know what the
VA stands for no idea
ask the wrong person do you know I do
know oh okay well do you want to
Enlighten us
it stands for Virginia like the state
because that's where Connor was born
born in Virginia yep ah nice yeah there
you go voice actor I don't think I've
met anyone from Virginia
yeah are you sure he's not just a voice
actor correct it is voice actor it does
stand for voice actor
you know what it could have been from
Virginia how do you guys know everything
about him huh
well you know he could he's Welsh he's I
think born and raised in Wales well I
didn't know that I didn't read
everyone's autobiography just read how
good they're at chess uh he is going to
be very proud to represent Virginia
no not a lot of stuff happens from there
so I would have understood this is some
good stuff in Virginia like you know
people like like Plymouth Jamestown
Jamestown Virginia or something the
founding fathers yeah yeah I know
there's three exciting stuff
all right we're going to Sea Dog stream
now Sea Dog Virginia
let's go go Virginia
this forward because I wanted to block
this off the king I don't want to come
down here and I thought there's no
benefit to taking this
well I like the song
I heard this is the national anthem in
Virginia
the national anthem from Virginia
obviously
this is the song the official song of
Virginia
I you know I think this is the match-up
if we can [__] you know it's not 100.
Chad does not like it's not bad but yes
no
add some
I think we're going back to the other
full screen there and yeah we heard
Connor say saikuno is not 100.
and it's true saikuno has definitely not
represented himself as a 100 in this
game but Connor's just too experienced
just too experienced and uh I'm glad
that I don't know I don't know if I
prefer that this match would have just
come first but like last it's you know
it'll be a bit faster than the others
but that's what happens I mean sometimes
there's going to be lopsided matchups
and that's okay that's why we have a
Champions and consolation bracket
oh man this is tough
you see Connor there vibing pushing the
pawns uh
wow he's he's trying to come in with a
rook mate okay
yeah Rook G4 stops the black king from
moving at all page four is a free Pawn
and just has to bring in the other Rook
celebrating to the Virginia Anthem
Virginia goes hard
yeah Virginia is the uh was voted the
number one toughest state in 2022
actually
I don't believe anything you say anymore
the poll was conducted by an independent
third party named Mogul moves uh yeah
good good oh all right what's the
solution there boys
now I know why he was jamming out
yep
nice
oh yeah no I didn't want to jam out
anyways it's okay take it away I like
the silence it's not copyrighted right
oh shoot that's probably look at these
dance moves these are great
this is good so disrespect this man is
dancing in the middle of his chess match
I mean yeah it's embarrassing whatever
do that dancing while they play chess
cringe
couldn't be me oh is that like is it
like a bota stream a week when you do it
it's all we do oh I do no but I meant
dancing on the opponent is pretty messed
up that's even better okay we got
fortnite danced on by a 13 year old as
he checkmated us so that's bad but I
have never seen a more Savage YouTube
title than when Alexandra uploaded a
video of her playing in Iceland and said
my opponent fell asleep during the game
well yeah I think what some people may
have done today but we're still here
let's go
her opponent fell asleep
chess the art of Chess that's a queen
and uh oh check King goes to the center
clean it up
and um Queen takes and that's game
unfortunately for Virginia Sea Dog VA
okay no just kidding debated gotcha
bro thanks easy cardu
and he's found it
he has found it
I'm waiting for him to say something
hey I like the energy Conor brings I
know he's a favorite but
he has he has good EDM music I can
I mean he got the job done that's all
you can ask you need the top seed to
perform he performed very confidently in
the first game
and he takes a one to nothing lead
versus saikuno well ladies and gentlemen
don't go anywhere because this next
matchup Anything Could Happen really you
must stay until the end if you don't
know and I heard you know Levy might
just do something really exciting at the
end of stream today
yes like go offline
and eat dinner uh I I I'm very tired and
this has been a very uh obviously long
day with all the technical difficulty so
I'm I'm breaking my diet and I'm I'm
gonna go get dessert because I I feel
very tired and I want to try what type
of dessert
um I'm gonna get like a nice chocolate
mousse cake ah chocolate mousse out of
everything you could have picked I'm
almost disappointed and wish I never
asked
okay
all right apparently chocolate mousse
herself I would eat like a like raw
cookie dough or something you know
something a little more on the edge
chocolate mousse you go with your
parents at Cheesecake Factory and like
don't have a lot of options on the menu
you just settled for the Moose I don't I
don't go to Cheesecake facts not a moose
type of girl I've never been anyway
I'm gonna ask the players about dessert
um
all right we're looking at saikuno uh he
he looks he looked I don't I don't know
I can't even make things happening it's
been five hours like he looks exactly
like the key always looks okay he always
boots up that stream he's always got the
nice intro music he's got the soothing
voice all right it's it's almost a shame
we're making him play chess you know
he's incredible he's an incredible gamer
I'm sure he would spend his evening like
20 different ways than this saikuno
thank you for playing in pot Champs all
right thank you uh we we need you all
right and wishing you the best of luck
in the second game he plays E4 I love it
he had a great showing I think he played
like a 500. can we get a uh if someone
behind the scenes can can somebody
analyze that game with game review and
tell me what his estimated ELO was
according to chess.com because I think
it was easily 500. I don't think it was
a hundred
that's my command my plea
look at this fantastic stuff look at
this Andrea this is
I I wish I did honestly now this is all
him
oh actually no I I do know he I watched
a little bit of his lesson with Nemo and
it was a line where he kept going Queen
H5 with the night there so okay I don't
think he'll give his Queen but yeah he
loves this one
hey you know gotta do what you gotta do
this is probably the best attempt
anyways wait a minute this is nuts I
mean like Connor's very close to losing
this game I mean I mean imagine this
could be the most insane win of all
pogchamp's history
go Bishop B3 please don't take
the bushes Save The Vicious saikuno
knows to save his [__] apparently
saikuno played at 73 accuracy last game
and a 700 ELO that's amazing yeah you we
need to share this with him so he
doesn't quit chess forever after today
because I'd like oh
no don't take it please just let us have
something God oh
oh Nemo taught him this because Sea Dog
had apparently lost the fried liver
before which I can see why but he forgot
to save his vicious yeah I mean 95 was a
dangerous move because after the bishop
would go back you have very easy ways oh
I was so confused with his camera I'm
sorry didn't mean to interrupt you go
ahead oh whose camera what camera
nothing I I'm seeing things just
continue
I see
um well the night is hanging so Sea Dogs
got to move it backwards and then if
cycuno just keeps being aggressive only
good things could happen so
okay maybe not don't don't do this now
don't play this because you lose the
queen so maybe Castle or Bishop F4 just
whatever you do not play just don't play
this move
just
okay you guys saw that too okay you had
some wide Zoom nice you guys well this
is just suffering but anyone wants to
tune into psychuno's dream because I
have to say it's kind of relaxing to
watch someone else suffer instead once
in a while
I don't I don't think I think
it's like who knows doing a great job I
don't
all right let's listen I'm gonna be
honest uh that was pretty much the only
Strat I actually kind of know and now
we're just freestyling from here so uh
and by freestyling I mean spamming
random moves and hoping they work uh so
yeah I'd uh
okay
I'm hoping he runs down the timer but I
don't think we'll be able to uh do that
he seems careful about the time and
realistically my only chance to win was
the hope you ran the timer out
so uh at least he's a realist yeah not
not looking great not looking great
I mean his position's good whatever I
did he seems to be thinking hard about
this move so that's good for me
um
do you like how hard he's thinking about
this move now
oh
interesting okay I'm gonna do this a
little little I mean he moved backwards
so I feel like that's a safe move
but uh we're obviously still way on the
back foot here he's doing some weird
Mumbo what he's doing I'm not 100 sure
but he's up to something
my guess is he's trying to go for my
horsey
so I'm going to move the horse no he's
just over here oh
no that was definitely not the Strat
there he's just trying to develop in
Castle
it you know
what else thank you forgot you could do
that maybe not the right stuff but I
forget anyway so he's trying it I
appreciate it and he was going for a lot
of weird I don't know what else to do
ah
okay
why would he do this
so this is a free Pawn
all right we're pulling up the analysis
board once again uh there was a moment
there it's like who knows said
that
uh Sea Dog was going for some weird
Mumbo and the horse and he moved it
uh that is that is Def that was
definitely not the objective for several
reasons to to hit this Knight you would
need to move this night but also the
Knight is defended so he's just trying
to develop and what I would urge
beginners to
um
not do is to give their opponents way
too much credit too early in the game
like
nobody really knows what they're doing
so
I know
completely knows what he's doing I agree
with him some weird mumbo jumbo
yeah
he's come back from this move E5
at some point his Knight is gonna have
to
come oh that's a good move I mean
keeping the pressure Connor yes no mercy
yeah too good just Pawn takes that's a
good move too though can't lie but just
here
wow
wow it's like what is Conor thinking
about by the way
he doesn't look pleased though
I don't care what
I'm looking
he looks very focused
he
all right psychuna's got a good
counter-attack plan
going to bring the attack on the queen
side this is good it's a plan
Bishop G4 okay if Connor responds with a
plan of his own the queen is hanging
don't take you could move or you could
block
you could move or you could block okay
he's the attack
I have to say no nope nope it's at the
100 level and that's impressive
this is next I think from psychuno
unless his moves are totally
unpredictable and I'm not going to be
able to anticipate anything he's either
going to go here or take the bishop
because he can
was kind of a spontaneous type of dude
you know he's just yes he's up on the
clock I think Connor's just struggling
to anticipate his moves and this is a
good shot when you're up against someone
a thousand points higher yeah if saikuno
pulls this game off by just playing
solidly until Connor runs out on of time
uh that will be the greatest victory in
all of pogsham's history uh
saikuno is a more than 1100 point
Underdog
but unfortunately Connor still has six
minutes on the clock
so uh maybe we could tune into Connor's
stream I don't know if he's talking but
he's got the title one posture so it
looks intense let's just I mean
and stressed is up a bishop
s
use a Die Hard Death Note
I think if he wins another game we have
to ask him to change the playlist
cool
oh what a mess
what a mess I've made
I love how dejected he is of a fantastic
position
this is what I honestly respect and can
take notes from lower rated players
because I always get very cocky or
confident as soon as I'm winning and I
throw but they are zoned in until the
last second
yeah they just constantly think they're
underperforming which which is very
funny like saikuno sitting there like I
got no clue what I'm doing Connor's like
I got no clue what I'm doing nobody
knows what they're doing apparently uh
and then saikuno can come back
he doesn't really have a choice he has
to play Knight C3
um
please don't do anything else
you don't have anything else psychuno
okay well he did that's not
dads that Pawn's gonna go to A2 this is
very bad
unfortunately he uh
he has thrown the Knight now for some
reason Conor is like terrified getting
in his head I don't know what's
happening but yeah Connor is just like I
mean he would take this in a heartbeat
against an 1100.
but
he's just not doing it
looks flustered
I think we've stumped him okay no there
it is there it is and and yeah white
just doesn't have enough I mean black is
just too solid and if you try to trade
this there's this you're just losing
pieces
and uh now uh
oh no
oh no he's just testing Conor's Vision
he wants to see if Conor is really
paying attention and how long he can see
diagonals there's a chance he fails this
test yeah he's kind of like a good
sparring partner and he did fail well
well uh well actually oh no because they
take with check I was gonna say we take
the bishop with the Knight attacking the
queen what surprise they take with the
check and you get nothing yeah yeah that
this this is either a flex or a total
accident that Rook is still hanging
and Connor just went forward so he might
find this now it does happen that way
sometimes
but yeah saikuno's kind of being a
sparring partner he's like yo Connor you
see The Rook I didn't see it so you
still you still got some work to do Rook
takes Pawn is and that's how you can
tell Levy's never Spartan his life
oh sorry what what what is what is uh
nothing sorry I didn't say anything
oh I see so your your coach just beats
you up or doesn't let you
train certain things
yeah yeah exactly
wait did this happen or was this oh I
don't even know what's happening anymore
oh it's like Uno well gave the Rook he
gave the queen
he just wants to give it all
oh he's speech he's speedrunning this in
Reverse one could say yeah
that's not that's not good
Queen is coming
ah
well
it was good for about
15 moves it's like watching someone beat
up a puppy I just don't want to watch
anymore
wow that's a that's that is an
escalation I mean I I feel as though he
kind of like felt like he was gonna lose
and he just he kind of threw it in it's
all good I mean Conor's coming in he
sees Queen F2 mate the only way to get
out of there is
to run the king or to bring the Knight
back Knight H3
Queen E3 is made in two or yeah you
could you could offer a draw Conor would
take a draw probably
Connor wins with a draw so maybe he'll
accept
now he's not accepting damn
Connor Jessica London yeah and Connor no
mercy clean yeah very very clean uh not
totally unexpected uh Conor was the
massive favorite
I think Conor was the biggest favorite
by rating in any first round matchup
here uh in the first round of POG James
the writing difference is huge though
but I mean especially the first game I
think he played really well
yep it was fun though I appreciate them
letting me
like chess and that I was late
if everyone else did you say he was late
bring you up
uh
it's okay Connor we forgive you yeah
it's really unfortunate we had to wait
on you all day geez Connor try to be
more on time next time it's Conor's
fault it's Connor's fault of course this
was a super uneven matchup and props to
both of them but saikuno played way
above his level had a lot of brilliant
moments and I hope this game doesn't
discourage him hopefully gets more
training but I think against a group of
players more closer to his rating he has
great chances
absolutely I think if he keeps
practicing he's got good chances against
other people in his group
but yeah I mean it's going to be very
tough to beat Connor not just for
saikuno but everybody in group a and
that goes for Jarvis
and that goes for Frank Frank beat
Jarvis today but Sea Dog is no walk in
the park he is a number he's the
probably the favorite to win the event
at least right now for a reason uh we
are going to go to a short break and I
we're gonna find out if we're going to
be speaking to one both or none of the
players I think some of them have time
constraints and we ran a bit late today
uh but the first day of box Champs 5 has
all finished and we will be right back
uh to let you know either uh the
interview or our thoughts before we sign
off
that is still plenty of options and
opportunities left all right next one
you ready yes that's the casparium study
why to move
yes
looks kind of familiar
but
okay yeah Rook D2 repeat here
so how do you start win a three Rotator
d206 A3 it would be two okay very nice
very nice
well done
okay
so it's Queen A3 check A2
then Rook B2 Rook A3 Rook B2 your entry
would be one very nice yeah very nice
yes
impressive knowledge
another study I mean if you know this
one
holy mightily impressed why to move okay
that's all I don't know
so it's 10 seconds as well 10 seconds oh
oh yeah the bishop B6 C5 and V8 uh B6
yes
indeed four H4 H4 uh
now I have to yes you can get five and
H5 and King E4 yeah very nice
as king E4 for the final move Bishop B6
Queen B6 C5 Queen B8 B6 King C8 King D4
yes H4 and king of five H five and King
B4 King before back yeah very nice
well done okay this one is a bit
difficult
so I guess Bishop takes B6 yes Queen B6
C5 yes Queen ba
B6 you can see a C7
Queen B7
uh C7 might not big oh
oh okay yes yes H4
you have Apollo G3 H5 and H6 right yes
okay attack five
exactly yeah very nice that's the one
yes
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps five where we see the
celebration
I don't know if that was the celebration
or just the mid-round dancing by Connor
and his match against uh saikuno today
we're joined by Our Last interviewee of
the day
how you doing how you doing baby you
feeling good how's the wind
baby
it's all things
oh gosh okay I did it gosh it's just her
thing I I just woke up and I thought
this is a great day to play some chess
um I was worried because psychuna is
known for
you know uh pulling a fast one and uh
the hundred rating I didn't believe it
for a second I'm glad I didn't I don't
want to go easy on him he's definitely
more than 100.
he definitely played above his level
uh he most certainly did he scabbed me
for a moment there I was I was about to
stop shooting myself sorry am I going to
curse on your stream I shouldn't I
should have like you watched that you
could you could do that you could do
that uh would you rather play 100 or
like a or like a 2000
oh two thousand hundred percent
there's like a 2 000 like when you're
when you're the higher rated
everything's on you to win and when you
win it's like wow look at this big man
with a big school winning huh look at
this guy uh so it doesn't feel too great
and I'm used to losing so I was really
happy to take that role
well on that note
you have kind of been touted I don't
know how much you've been following
because I know you're a busy guy but
you've been touted as the pre-tournament
favorite there's obviously a couple of
other people in the four digits and
there's a few people who really over
perform today they played super super
well so do you know are you aware that
you are the pre-tournament favorite are
you thinking about that at all are you
training it's a lot of pressure on you I
heard you beat loving
who's the favorite for who who uh
the whole thing
no way dude I
actually got a thousand dollars on you
I literally put all my money on you yeah
like I I did a lot of history and you
know you you played Rivals three years
ago you played chess as a kid they told
me you'd be Ludwig so I put all of my
almost my entire college fund on you so
yeah
it's like you know blind could beat
Ludwig that's not that's nothing to be
a thousand
yeah well you know I mean it's it's
something like that but he plays like
100 that's what matters I think the
thing that I'm concerned about is
um if I do well that I will have more
pressure on me and then also I have to
get a flight to L.A which I've done so
she's really dreading going to lay down
come on L.A really can we not do it in
Tokyo yeah every time I every time I'm
in La you're in La I feel like you're in
La all the time I mean it's uh
wait I have a question if you
if you make it to the final
yeah you are the favorite you are you're
definitely the favorite 100 like it's
close but you're definitely the favorite
if you make it out there to uh to and
you you go to the final will you rematch
lud in slot fighting
yo I'll rematch him and slap fighting I
wouldn't mind doing that
okay wow look at that uh maybe for
charity
uh listen I don't mind getting slapped
full stop let's just we can just arrange
that
um especially if I get to slap lubbard
back that's a win-win for me I think my
strategy going forward with this is to
uh continue to not practice and then
when I lose I can blame that I didn't
practice and that I should have
practiced more
my whole career right there
same except I practice and still lose I
think this is great we're all really
gonna be rooting you on and I will make
sure it's embed even more money I think
he's a clear favorite I love to see the
enthusiasm the motivation to take the
win home
you guys proud
yeah Connor the last question before you
go I don't know how much scouting you've
done of the groups you've got a guy in
your group who has made chess popular in
the in in England uh he's an Englishman
his name is Frank are you excited to
represent in that rivalry in that
matchup uh yeah if he's from England I'm
from Wales so it's a natural-born
rivalry
um I've seen Frank France's presence is
terrifying he's a he's a powerful man
and his Aura is much higher than mine
however I you know I I like to think
that my calm demeanor would allow me to
focus more
um but we'll see we'll see but Frank
Frank is a Powerhouse I don't know how
I'm gonna compete against Frank
then you could take him in an open mic
match
[__] no I think he breaks the mic
I heard that Frank will only play you if
it's open mike so we might have no
choice
I just understood what you meant by open
mind sorry I thought for some reason I
thought it was like a shouting
competition have you been like play no
no no just yeah yeah
would that be allowed do we have your
permission okay cool
headquarters got it yeah they'll arrange
this yeah as long as we don't have to
hear it uh we don't have to hear the
concert yeah
all right oh God I play so much worse
when I play Open Mic but sure I'll do it
again
you heard it here
I'm in a very exciting stuff yeah we got
an open mic match with Frank we got a
[__] we got Connor into a lot of stuff
here ending the show it's been it's been
a wild time Connor thank thank you for
uh being a good sport sticking around
for the show running late uh welcome to
five
and I'll let you go I'll let you go
enjoy the day over there in Japan bye
thank you so much
I will I will thank you so much guys see
you guys bye bye Connor bye uh bye to
Connor's chat let's take a look at our
standings
uh
the first day is done Group D untouched
we didn't have any matchups there we got
the entirety of group a
Sea Dog and Frank
both three points up top defeating
saikuno and Jarvis respectfully
respectively respectfully as well but
also respectively uh in group b gasly
took a quick lead
with a three-point victory over daily
dose of Internet
and uh tyler1 getting us going in group
C with the winner Virginia
uh we saw Frank celebrating
he yelled a lot
a lot we saw
gasly just
you know
I guess they're just very chill
very very chill there and
same goes for Tyler very calm collected
man
yep very comfortable those arms are
gigantic goodness and then he challenged
me to a 1v1 and there's Connor
he challenged you to a 1v1 yeah people
in the chat were saying Tyler wants the
1v1 me hopefully please take it
I would I would fly to him and do like a
weightlifting competition just to see
how much weaker I am
um and I'm I'm not that weak but he is
just ridiculously strong it's so cool to
see uh that that about wraps it up
um we've gotta we've got coverage
tomorrow uh and I think we are going to
preview what we expect
uh I don't know if I mean I'm here Andre
are you my co-host tomorrow I don't know
who my co-host is nope it's gonna be
Amman oh okay I'm on Hamilton Grand
Master I'm on Hamilton look at that uh
yeah something I don't
um
oh the Grand Master title Jesus okay
oh my God all right uh all right
um xqc squeaks 5 p.m Eastern tomorrow
Gastly we got gasly two days in a row
what a treat just letting my students
tomorrow I've been coaching them both
so I can't watch I can't watch yeah I'm
secretly training snap assessment snap
snap snap snap
and you you fake to be a supportive
coach on Twitter you don't even know his
name
I I know his name and then we got Connor
coming back to play Jarvis tomorrow too
wow I did you know what I I didn't even
know any of this I didn't know that
people are playing playing twice okay
well I will be here uh tomorrow and I
guess uh it'll be myself and I'm on
Hamilton we got only three matchups
tomorrow because creators are very busy
people and they have real jobs not just
playing chess matches on chess.com
during POG Champs but we will get all of
the group stages completed tomorrow
we've only got three matches
and that about concludes day number one
uh what a day what a day all right tired
I look forward to your commentary
tomorrow I hope it's even longer than
today oh wow three matches but longer
wow that will be awful that will be yeah
yeah that's gonna be terrible it's the
test of how much it takes to break Levy
and I test myself I've gone pretty close
but I want to see you can take the cake
no no definitely not uh none of this is
real and we all die in the end and on
that beautiful note welcome back to
pawchamps it's POG Champs five it's day
number one in the books a lot of great
matches
a lot of Great Moments and we're gonna
sign off but before we do
uh we've got a we've got a question if
you're looking to put your bullet chess
skills to the test oh now there's a
weekly competitive event called the
community bullet brawl Arena finally
when I can play in yay yes you can and
you can win a diamond membership anybody
able to throw their head in the ring and
prove their speed chess prowess I'm
reading off a card so let me just all
you have to do is join the Community
Club on chess.com and register for the
arena use the command CBB in the chat
for all of the details are you gonna
you're gonna plan it I think I might I
keep asking them and only playing title
Tuesday but bullet brawl might be my big
break
it might I'm not gonna play because I'm
I'm an old man I don't play bullet
anymore uh that's our community bullet
ball Arena
this is pogchamps five
we're signing off day number one
coverage it's been great we'll see you
all tomorrow I think it's at 3 30 p.m
Eastern that could have been I think
it's a 3 P.M Eastern that could be
completely incorrect we'll put out an
announcement it's been a long day thank
you so much for joining us and we'll see
you all tomorrow welcome back to pog
Champs everybody
five minutes left I'm sure you taught
Frank about stalemate
go over the mouse just just do it Queen
tissue is made on the board
oh my God
amazing Eddie resigns let's go D4 is
played
it's me the game that won't end
Knight takes Queen is made by it's over
all right look at this setup for the
ladder mate
whoa you can do that it's getting tricky
oh you can't move your crown man like
that takes takes and then after just
there's takes and then there's takes but
there is takes but look at these dance
moves these are great
yeah and Connor no mercy
foreign
all the way
through the window
[Music]
thank you
Channel
s
[Music]
this is
one two one
foreign